In four,
three,
two,
one.
Hey Jimmy.
What's up?
Hi Joe.
How you doing?
Doing good now we're on the radio.
Fantastic.
It's 3:31
minutes before 4:00.
Here's vow with the weather.
Hot.
Hottest.
Fuck back to you Jimmy.
Bob.
So how are we going to car fire in the
breakdown lane.
So you were getting emotional in the
green room listening to Henry rollins
talk about Putin.
You're about to quote Chomsky like.
Yes.
So he was,
I just caught the end of it.
I sent,
went in the green room and I like,
you know,
everybody loves Henry Rollins.
Right?
And Sam Henry twice.
So good.
He's constantly grinding.
Yeah.
But he was doing that thing about.
Oh,
poot.
And you know there was a journalist who
wrote a book about them,
ended up dead.
Putin's a bad guy.
He's a bad guy as opposed to who?
Well,
no,
but he,
you,
you mean he's definitely a bad guy,
right?
We all agree that course.
But I mean just because other people are
also bad guys.
It doesn't negate his point of Putin
being a bad guy.
What he was saying is just that.
It's very bizarre that the Republicans,
these people that were at the forefront
of the Cold War,
these ones always,
I mean these are the people that
remember Khrushchev Banging on the desk
saying,
we'll bury you with,
with Kennedy and these people are now
like the whitewashing Putin.
They're essentially like trying to paint
out Putin to be a good guy because trump
is in this position where he's trying to
be friends with this guy.
So.
Well here's the quote I wanted to send
you.
Right?
So that whole thing,
if,
if Nuremberg laws were applied,
then every post war American president
would have been hanged since says Noam
Chomsky,
a Putin kills journalists.
We just torture hours.
Let me.
Chelsea manning is a whistleblower.
We took Brock Obama torture.
So we have our president,
we have presidents and vice presidents
who are legit war criminals that walk
around today,
that a torture program.
Okay.
So,
uh,
you know,
Barack Obama got a peace prize and then
he had a kill list.
How a peace prize winner with a kill
list at drone kill it.
Would you keep the kill list next to the
peace prize?
Where do you keep those two things?
Are they anyway,
so that's some of the people that were
killed were American citizens with no
due process,
no due process.
And so nobody has a problem with trump.
Being buddy buddies with Benjamin
Netanyahu is a psychopathic maniac who
shoots,
who shoots with precision,
uh,
medics who are trying to help people in
nurses hand journalists,
by the way.
Well,
some is really true.
Israeli troops do that.
That's a really depressing thing.
You know,
I had abby Martin on and she sort of
illuminated that whole situation to me.
I really didn't know how bad it was,
nor did she until she went over there.
Right.
And you know,
just experiencing what it's like the,
it's crazy that people that went through
the
Holocaust that realize the cost of
dehumanizing an entire race of people
now are capable,
at least some of them are capable of
doing that to the Palestinians.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's kind of mind blowing.
So I want to hear,
and I have friends who do that.
Everyone's doing this right?
Everyone's getting caught up in this
hysteria.
That's why there's a word called
hysteria because it happens and Lauryn
one,
and you know what I like is what Noam
Chomsky said about this Russia hysteria
that's happening.
He said,
if you care about effects on our
pristine elections,
which he said very sarcastically,
he said,
if you care about what's affecting our
pristine elections to Russia,
gate is the last place I would look,
and the first place he would look.
If you're worried about four and a
control of or influence on our
government.
He said he would look to Israel.
They're the ones.
Benjamin Netanyahu came here and address
the joint session of Congress without
the permission or invitation of the
president,
my bro,
when Obama was president and he did
that.
He did that.
That's a guy coming here to tell our
guys how to vote in direct defiance of
our president and everyone embraced him.
Can you imagine the food and did that
boot and came to America and addressed
the joint session of Congress against
the will of the president.
So this idea that somehow because Putin
is a bad guy,
trump shouldn't have a good friendship
with them.
Is Bs the guys who are really
influencing our government.
Here are Benjamin Netanyahu,
Saudi Arabia,
but trump opened eight businesses in
Saudi Arabia during the election.
No one gives a crap about any of that
stuff because they're our friends.
Saudi Arabia,
by the way,
just bombed us school today.
A school bus,
29 kids dead.
So yeah,
I just retweeted that from Sarah Abdula.
So,
uh,
why would they do that?
Because they're in Yemen.
They're,
they're,
they're bombing.
We were committing genocide in Yemen
right now.
So we're helping Saudi Arabia committed
genocide in Yemen.
And the way we're doing it is they're
doing a thing called siege warfare,
which is a war crime.
And we just,
in fact they just prosecuted someone a
few months ago in a,
at the Hague for it.
So,
but since we're doing it and we're the
enforcers and Saudi Arabia is on the
human rights council.
So everything's a joke now,
right?
So we were past it where it's a farce.
We're living in this forest.
And so when I see a guy that I love,
like Henry Rollins,
I'm saying stuff like,
oh Putin's this special,
kind of bad.
I just called back Chomsky out.
We have nothing.
We have legit war criminals.
Just one presidency away.
Do you think he's a step removed from
that though?
I mean he,
he'll assassinate journalists in his own
country right now.
Right now we're trying to assassinate
Julian assange right now are trying to
do.
They're trying to kill that guy.
Yes.
They want at that guy dead heavily.
Hillary Clinton's campaign.
We drone that guy,
can't we kill them?
And she really did say that.
She really did say that after she just
got done killing Kadafi and then laughed
about it,
that we've played that several times we
came,
we saw he died.
The fact that fact
that any human being would ever do that,
that.
And by the way,
the way he died,
that's some dark shit they watched and
they stabbed him in the ass hole.
There's a video of him stabbing him in
the asshole.
I standing there just confused.
Not knowing what to do in this guys
jamming a sword up his ass.
Have you seen the video?
I have not seen.
Oh my God,
it's awful.
You want to see,
you know,
the video,
them capturing him is fascinating
because it's a guy who has lived with an
iron fist,
controlled these people.
Been a brutal dictator.
Been a horrible monster of a human
being.
Now all of a sudden these rebels have
captured him and they can't believe they
have.
I mean,
they're shooting and stabbing him.
And then eventually they have his body
and they prayed his body around after
they've killed them.
But there's,
there's,
there's video of him should look at it
for just for a moment because it's so
stunning to see him captured and alive
and can't believe that these rebels have
him.
That it's not even.
It's not even like,
yeah,
I have seen video of him captured and
that look on his face.
So I know what you're talking about.
Just the guy's shoving.
But I did not.
I shoving a knife up his ass.
I um,
I hit a dog with my car awhile ago and I
just can't have no stomach for any of
that stuff anymore.
I just a,
I don't,
something went,
ha ha.
I had a real breakdown.
Like we took it to the vet.
It lived.
I didn't hit,
I didn't.
So I hit it.
I hit a dog,
killed it a bout a year and a half ago.
He might have already been dead already
been done because I think it was laying
in the street because I didn't see it.
So it had to be already laying there
anyways,
so it,
you know,
I just.
And then I saw I was driving to my pot
store and Eagle Rock and I saw this
little black puppy dog run across the
street in front of our car and there was
this big median,
like a grass median and it was good and
I go,
stop,
stop.
And the cards hasn't started coming it
the other way and I stopped saying my
wife stops and I jumped out and I'm
running and I see the cars coming and
they're just,
I don't see the dog anymore.
And then I see the dog next to the curb
and it's Kinda like,
just going like that and it just crushed
me.
He's like,
even now to think of it switching.
Yes,
it got hit.
And so,
um,
we,
we pick it up and we,
we drove to a hospital as soon as we
could.
I mean,
you know,
the Animal Hospital,
which there was one not far away and it
lived,
the dog lived,
but I couldn't believe it.
You take it as a pet.
they just might.
My wife called back,
you know,
to the thing and they said,
yeah,
it's going to live in.
We have someone who's going to take it
like,
okay,
thank God.
But I was so surprised at how I just
broke down over that puppy.
The dog I ran over,
I was like numb to but that dog for some
reason that just everything opened and I
was just,
I couldn't,
it was such a basket case puppy's so
cute.
It was such,
I was hit by a car at such a how can.
So it's just like,
I see and I,
and I feel like I don't know if I have
this,
but I feel like I have ptsd over that,
right.
Like I way over reacted to that
situation so there was a lot more going
on there.
And so when someone says something like
the Kadafi video.
Yeah.
So I can't even imagine guys who have to
go to war and the stuff they have to see
and the things that they have to do.
I don't know how they all don't come.
You know,
anybody who went over there.
Yeah,
I,
I've been,
I've been to Afghanistan soldiers.
I mean,
but uh,
uh,
yeah.
I mean I'd known that.
Not Personally,
like they come to my show,
that kind of stuff.
I know those people.
I don't have a close friend who was
actually in combat like that.
No.
I have a few close friends that have
been in combat and when they start
drinking and that's when,
you know,
inhibitions get loosened up and then
stories start flowing and you know,
it's most people,
but it's not something people are
designed to see,
you know,
especially not when.
No one else is seeing it.
The thing is if we all lived in the
Roman times and everybody was getting
sorted up every day and people getting
hit with arrows all the time,
it's a normal part of life when people
start accepting the fact that there's
going to be lost,
but there's something about living today
where the majority of human beings live
in this uber safe environment that's
probably a safe more safe than any
people who've ever lived ever.
And just overall in general,
like the modern Western civilization.
But then you're going over to
Afghanistan and you're,
you're,
you know,
you're dealing with bombings and schools
and buses and sniper attacks and you
know,
your buddy just lost a leg from an ied
and you know,
that that kind of shit just wears on a
person.
Yeah.
Just any,
any,
anything?
I.
Oh,
I can't,
I can't believe we still do more like
this.
It's just,
you know,
I'm very.
See I get it a lot of trouble because
I've antiwar and all words are bullshit
and get in trouble because you're
antiwar.
For instance,
pro war,
uh,
the entire establishment is pro war.
You know that every,
every newscaster is pro war.
If you're on,
if you're not pro war,
you don't get on TV.
If you're against the war,
you get fired.
Like Phil Donahue,
like Ed Schultz,
like Jesse Ventura,
like Ashley Banfield,
fear.
If you tell Chris Hedges,
if you tell the truth about the war,
you will get fired from establishment
news
establishment and use that will let you
talk openly other than Artie.
Artie seems to be pretty open,
which is really ironic.
It's ironic,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
when Abby Martin was working for,
it was like Jesus Christ,
like,
wow,
how's that work?
No.
At the empire files and you're working
for Russia.
I know.
It does seem crazy.
It's a crazy,
crazy juxtaposition.
It is weird.
Ed Schultz was the one who said that,
uh,
you know,
he wasn't.
He was told what to cover,
what not to cover at MSNBC.
He was told not to cover Bernie Sanders.
He wanted to cover Bernie Sanders.
Anyway,
he said that the Hillary Clinton
campaign and the head of NBC News,
Andy Lack.
We're joined at the hip and he tried to
cover Bernie Sanders.
He was told not to,
he was yelled at by the head of MSNBC,
how he described it,
and a month later he was fired.
He was out.
Well,
Jack had a similar situation,
Jack from the young Turks,
just that he was told that,
uh,
our friends in Washington don't like
your tone.
Oh my God,
that's what they told him.
That is hilarious.
And he was winning his time slot and
they told them that and they moved into
the weekend to give out sharp.
This is true,
this is true.
So they moved them to the weekend and
they said they wanted him to work on his
presentation skills.
Guys.
Wedding is time.
Plot their segment.
We want you to work on your presentation
skills.
And meanwhile who they replaced them
with Al Sharpton.
He's got great presentation skills.
That's all.
Al Has sued on Al Sharp.
Did you ever see him try to read a
teleprompter is brutal.
Yeah.
I mean he's a great order,
but he's not a teleprompter reader and
it was like I have clips we used to make
fun of all the time on my show.
If curious and then find out that that's
the reason they gave was because he's a
better presenter.
He's better.
He's a great order.
That's different than being a news
presenter and that is not in Al
Sharpton's wheelhouse.
No,
it's just he's not the most trustworthy
person either.
I mean he's got a history of deception.
So you having that,
the way he got that job?
Yeah.
Well how about the way he became famous,
the Tawana Brawley case.
I mean he became famous through
deception and so you're seeing this guy
who is basically a famous con man who's
now on television on a news program.
Well,
they have.
There's a lot.
Look at Brian Williams.
Yes,
yes.
He has the 11th hour at an MSNBC,
so since everybody forgotten,
everybody has forgotten.
I got.
His punishment was he had to.
He had to go spend six months a giggling
with Rachel maddow.
What did he do?
Something show.
They do these shows.
They have like these round tables.
At the end he has to laugh and pretend
they all pretend they fucked up about
him.
All he had to do is tell the truth and I
was scary enough.
No Shit.
I mean,
you were in Iraq.
He really were there.
Were there?
Yeah.
I mean,
you really were there.
Or Afghanistan.
Was it Iraq or Afghanistan?
I think it was a wreck.
And you're really.
Shots were fired.
Hillary did the same goddamn thing.
Oh,
that's right.
She lied about being shot at fucking
straight up.
Lied about being in Bosnia.
Right.
And,
and who was it?
The was the comedian who outed her.
It was a sinbad.
Sinbad who was on that trip and he's
like sniper.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
She was busted straight up,
lying about being shot at.
So it's just,
it's always shocking to me when I find
out it had.
Politicians are lying.
Isn't it so true?
They're all dark.
That's weird.
It's,
it's such a.
only the purest of people are drawn to
that,
but freshman,
it's whenever I find out they're
narcissists.
Megaliters,
narcissistic megalomaniacs.
I'm always shocked.
You know what it is,
Jimmy?
We're weeding out the bad apples and
then we're eventually gonna get to the
good ones.
Yeah.
We got to get rid of these bad ones
first.
So that's why it comes back to when he
was talking about how Putin,
he is like,
Hey,
I want to tell trump,
slow down.
Don't be friends with this guy.
No,
I want trump to be friends with Putin
because he's a nuclear power.
I want trump to be friends with anybody.
We need detente.
NATO is the one wrapping up tensions,
ramping up tensions with Russia and we
have ever since the Cold War,
it supposedly ended and so it was just a
few anyways.
So I just think,
yes,
Putin has a bad guy.
They're all bad guys.
Right?
There's why I,
you know,
I just had John Kiriakou on my show.
I don't know,
is he?
So he is a FCA guy.
He went to prison because he exposed the
torture program.
Oh yeah.
So Robert Mueller actually prosecuted
that guy.
So now he's,
he's a member of veterans intelligence
professionals for sanity,
Vips.
And they were,
uh,
they were invented or they were
originally organized to debunk the
weapons of mass destruction about Iraq.
So they were intelligence professionals
who knew what was happening that we're
being sold a bill of goods because the
military industrial complex wanted it's
war.
Right.
And so they,
they were like all the top guys,
ray mcgovern,
Bill Binney,
and they,
and they created this organization to
help debunk.
It will open.
He is the guy who was the first whistle
blower for the NSF.
Correct.
And they tried to throw in the FBI,
tried to throw him in jail.
And of course he's the smartest guy at
the NSA of her head.
So he outsmarted the FBI.
Well how did they do that?
So he had the story,
but I forget the story,
he told it to me,
but he had them secretly recorded saying
certain things.
And so when they tried to show the
evidence against him,
he was like,
actually I got you guys.
And they're like,
oh shit.
And so they could.
So he had him.
So he outsmarted them and he tells the
story on my show and you know,
it was about a year ago,
so I don't remember exactly how it went.
But he told me a lot of mindblowing
stuff on my show,
a lot of stuff just to,
um,
you know,
like about how they spy on us.
Well,
he was the one that first expose this
program that was essentially spying on
every single email,
every single voicemail,
every single conversation that you have
is being recorded.
So William Binney invented a thing
called thin thread.
So thin thread was a data collection.
So what he did is he hooked up every
cell phone to every cell phone in the,
in the universe.
It's,
and he did it and it was hard to do and
everybody said you couldn't do it.
He did it.
And so he knew that medidata.
What was more predictive than say,
if I tap your phone and listen to your
actual phone conversation,
that I actually learned more by looking
at a larger data set.
And when,
when,
when context start happening,
that means movements happening.
That means that attack is going to
happen.
That means more so if the metadata means
more.
And so he found a way to attract people
and keep your identity secret.
So it was constitutional.
That's what he cared about,
the constitution and the right to
privacy and thin thread did that it was
a better and,
and they got rid of thin thread and a
couple of weeks later,
nine slash 11 happened.
So that's what built.
So that's who bill binney is.
And so he said they got rid of it
because there's billions of dollars in
the do pro.
They brought in a,
a,
uh,
I think it was called trailblazer out
and not as good as a tracker,
not as good as a metadata thing and,
but it was five,
$6,000,000,000
to Booz Allen or whoever invented it.
And that's what it's all about is it's
all about money and you don't want to
disappoint people who want to have a lot
of money paid their way.
And then.
So that's what.
So he blew the whistle on that and they
come back at them and they tried to put
him in jail.
That's what they do to whistleblowers.
That's what we do.
So that's funny to hear him say,
oh,
somebody wrote a bad book about Putin
and they ended up dead.
What do you think we do in this country?
Look what they did to Chelsea manning.
Look what we did to people who expose
war crimes inside of our country right
now.
We're trying.
They're trying to assassinate Juliana
sons.
They haven't been basically solitary
confinement.
We literally did torture Chelsea
Manning.
So,
uh,
and then,
you know,
Barack Obama used,
uh,
he,
he prosecuted lots of whistleblowing
journalists using the non.
Blanking on the word it's called,
but,
um,
espionage act.
So this idea that,
yeah,
I'm sure poor,
maybe Putin didn't.
Maybe that woman who wrote that book
about Putin has a lot of powerful
enemies.
Usually you do when you are that kind of
been a journalist where you're exposing
the powerful.
She probably didn't just expose booton.
So she probably exposed a lot of people.
My point being is that,
uh,
you know,
now who's being naive gay?
Well,
I mean she probably did expose a lot of
people,
but it's also very likely that Putin
enter.
Yes.
And I'm not,
I'm not denying that Barack Obama had a
kill list.
So these guys are out,
you know,
he,
he took us from two hours to seven.
He did Libya,
turned it into a failed state.
Right now they have open slave trading.
No,
you're watching on youtube.
So dark.
And they wanted to do it again.
They want to do it in Syria.
They want.
So Joe,
let me ask you a question.
If we get rid of Assad in Syria,
do you know who takes over?
Uh,
the Jesus?
That's right.
Who starts running things,
Moses,
Elka,
al Qaeda,
El Nuestra.
Yeah.
Uh,
so that the power vacuum that always
happens.
The,
uh,
the,
the Wahhabi terrorist funded by Saudi
Arabia,
that's who takes over and I have video
tape after videotape of our top
officials admitting that Saudi Arabia
Funds Isis and that we also did so and
that we created,
we created al Qaeda,
we got,
we create an isis was created because of
our invasion of Iraq,
but then we actually fund them and we
ship them arms.
So for what reason?
To overthrow aside.
So we can put a pipeline through Syria.
So we fund them so that they fight
Assad.
But then Saudi Arabia funds,
this isn't the first time we did that.
We funded to Al Ida.
So they would fight the Russians.
Right.
So this is the same.
And then we were left with them.
When was the mujahideen?
That's when they were the moon.
Yes.
Hi Dean.
So,
and I have videotapes of Hillary Clinton
screaming about this.
We created this problem.
She says this on video.
I have it.
So,
um,
that's why I get trouble because I tell
the truth about the war.
And if you tell the truth about the war,
you'll be called a conspiracy theorist
by the establishment news.
That's exactly what's happened.
That happened to me.
Or you conspiracy theorist?
No,
that's what they say.
You know what the biggest,
because I tell the truth about Syria,
right?
Uh,
the biggest conspiracy in my lifetime
was the Iraq war.
That was a conspiracy.
Yeah.
That's legit.
That's a legit conspiracy.
Yeah.
I mean that's when you can actually
prove right.
I mean I used to have a whole bit about
it.
I used to have a whole bit about like
the,
the only way to find out if someone was
like from 2005,
it was that the reason why they put
George Bush and power is the only way to
find out if someone is really stupid is
to put an actual stupid guy in his
president and find out if everybody
freaks out because the only way to
really tell.
And we're like,
well we could put a smart guy in there
and have Mac.
I'm like,
no,
no.
We'll never know.
We'll get it.
We get a dumb guy.
Let's just try it out and see what
happens.
And then it was all the whole thing
about us going to war in Iraq.
Like why did we go to the war over there
and why?
What did we tell them?
And they bought that Holy Shit.
And then he won again.
He won again.
Fuck.
And then I go and you know,
there's someone in the back of the room
going,
I think we can go dumber.
And that became trump.
I mean,
that was from 2005 from my showtime
special from 13 years ago.
Uh,
let me tell you something,
trump,
it will be allowed to be president and
was allowed to be president because he's
doing the bidding of the establishment.
They're on board with most of the stuff
he's doing there like that.
He's,
he's not,
he's not pulling back on any of the
wars.
He's,
they've all ramped up the military
budget.
Isn't it funny Joe not protecting him
from you or they're not protecting him
from this,
this investigation?
Well,
he's.
Nothing's happened.
Again,
it's,
and by the way,
what they've gotten them on is all
regular corruption.
Like I said,
trump is corrupt.
Yes,
he's corrupt.
He's corrupt with Saudi Arabia.
He's corrupt with Russia.
He grew up with Israel.
He's get,
they're all corrupt,
but he thought the Clinton Foundation
and they're there all the chomsky quote,
they'd all be hung if we applied the
Nuremberg standards.
So this is the world we're living in.
So this idea that somehow we need to
focus extra on trump and somehow poot.
And you know what,
journalists,
the Anti Putin journalists in Russia
will tell you that we're a bunch of
numbskulls over here because we're
inflating Putin's power.
So we are blood like he's this all
powerful guy who's got his finger in
every decision everywhere at all times.
Ellison mulattoes now blaming the Green
party being controlled by the Russians
for an Ohio election.
A special election.
I'm not kidding.
I could show you some Milana and I.
Who Doesn't love Alyssa Milano,
right?
She's beautiful.
She's one of the prettiest of all time.
I met her in a hotel once.
Did you really wandering through the
hotel.
We got an elevator together.
So here is can't believe him in a hotel
elevator with just not as I said hello.
She said hello back.
And that was it.
Did she know who you were?
I don't think so.
No.
This is a long time ago too.
She says,
you know what sucks,
because of our unwillingness to pass
policy that protects our election
integrity.
I immediately think the Green party
votes.
And tonight's our Russian meddling.
Why else would eddie would cast a
protest vote in Ohio when there's so
much at stake?
So much at stake.
That's so delusional.
What is it?
Protest vote.
What's your vote worth?
If everyone votes and they all vote
green,
is that a protest vote?
If it is possible that the Green party
can win,
like do you have no faith?
So what they're doing is essentially
just bowing down to a rig system saying
the system is rigged,
so just vote for side b,
even though side a and b are funded by
the same people I know,
I know,
but ideologically side B is our side.
That's what she's saying.
So what they've gone past.
So now the hashtag resistance have gone
beyond voters shaming and now what
they're actually doing is democracy
shaming.
You don't get to participate in
democracy and those people.
So let me tell you something.
When people say,
Oh,
you know,
the Greens take away vote.
I would not have voted in the
presidential election if I did not have
the opportunity to vote for the Green
Party.
Just so those votes,
you don't own those votes.
The way electoral politics works is that
if you don't have enough votes to win,
you have to go get them and you have to
appeal to those votes,
but they don't have an appeal to voters.
The Democratic Party,
they have nothing,
and so what they have left is fear and
voter shaming and that's it.
Now they're actually shaming democracy.
Well,
you would also think that by the time
after we've gotten through this past
election where no one,
literally no one in the mainstream
media,
then maybe Fox News predicted that trump
was gonna win,
no one.
They all were 100 percent sure hillary
was gonna win.
They were.
They were had in the 90 percent range of
probability of her winning and they were
displaying it on cnn so they know that
that's wrong.
So why would someone think that a Green
party candidate has to be,
or a libertarian candidate has to be a
protest vote?
Why can't it be a real vote at this
point when you're talking about the kind
of social media outreach that is capable
today that's possible today,
what you a person who has some really
good points,
and as I look at this woman who wanted
in New York,
the 28 year old girls a democratic
socialist,
Alessandra ocozzio plant says,
look,
if that doesn't tell you like this world
is changing in a radical way and
upstarts and and,
and people who are huge underdogs have
the possibility of winning.
It's not a protest vote.
It's an actual vote.
And if everybody who thinks this way
votes towards that protest vote,
guess what?
They win.
That's right.
That's what it is.
So I used to have a joke or I would say,
no,
you can't vote for.
You can vote for a third party candidate
until a lot of people already voting for
a third party candidate.
Exactly.
That's what they're saying.
You can't vote for.
They have no chance to win.
So you have to wait until a lot of
people are already so that people don't
understand that inherent contradiction.
And by the way,
people maybe if you spent a 10th of the
energy trying to excite the half of the
country that doesn't vote as you do and
trying to voter shame progressive's or
Green Party or environmentalist for not
giving you their vote,
what you do not fucking own,
you would've spent a 10th of the energy
trying to excite people who don't
participate to participate.
Instead of shaming the people who do
participate.
Maybe you'd get somewhere.
It's also this reluctance to admit that
both sides are corrupt,
is this very strange thing that exists
on people who operate within those
narrow bandwidth.
In this narrow bandwidth is whatever
side you're on,
whether it's you're on the right or the
left,
this is the side that you want to win
and it's the right side and they're the
good people and the other side,
even though,
well,
even though our side does wrong,
this side does worse and they operate in
this real narrow bandwidth.
This is why she would think something
that's possibly negative for her side is
a protest vote.
Instead of being your actual feelings on
the issue,
and if these people really cared about
voting integrity,
wouldn't they want paper ballots?
If they really cared about a voter
integrity,
wouldn't they want rank choice voting
when they want that?
Then you don't,
you don't,
you don't have to worry about this
choice voting choice.
So they have it in Maine now,
right?
So,
uh,
it's where,
so,
you know,
you,
you get to,
this is my first choice.
This is my second choice.
This is my third choice.
So you don't get to.
So it eliminates that.
You're a spoiler,
right?
It's just.
Yeah.
So,
um,
and,
and they voted in,
in Maine and the politicians of course
don't want it.
So they got rid of it and the court
reinstated.
It hadn't been.
I think it's happened twice.
Now.
How does it work
in terms of like say if you're going to
vote for a governor of Maine,
you have a first choice.
A second choice.
Okay.
Let's say,
let's say there's three choices.
So you get to,
you get to say,
well,
let's say,
let's say if your first choice was a
green party candidate and you go,
okay,
that's my first choice,
but my second choice would be the
Democrat.
So in my third choice would be maybe
nobody.
And so does second choice have different
points.
So if you that,
if your first choice doesn't get enough
votes to win,
then your second choice goes,
right?
So that's how it works.
So you're never wasting your vote.
And you know,
what's ironic is that,
and I might have,
you know,
there's people who can better explain
that simply.
I know people are going be jamie the
weighty,
better way to say that I,
I'm sure there's better ways,
but the thing that kills me is that
Bernie Sanders,
his whole career was about being an
independent.
And I have video tapes of him saying,
you know,
what kills me.
This is like,
what do I do?
These talks that I talk to people,
they come up to me after these debates
and they said,
you know,
I like what you said and uh,
you,
you make the most sense.
But I can't vote for you because you
never going to win.
I hate that they go,
I want to waste my vote.
Oh,
if there's one thing I hate more than
that phrase,
waste your vote.
This was what he was saying his entire
career until now.
And I want to know why.
I want to know what the hell does Bernie
Sanders in 2018 know that Bernie Sanders
in 2006 didn't know.
And Bernie Sanders in 1996 doesn't know.
And he tells everybody you got to run.
He's,
you know,
getting people to come into the
Democratic Party,
which is actively cheating them yet he's
still seeing and him.
And he still runs as an independent in
Maine.
I mean in Vermont.
He still runs it.
Everybody say you guy,
you can see he gets to run as an
independent.
He gets the running as an independent
while represented.
Democratic Party.
Yes.
So they have a special sweetheart deal
is.
What is he saying when he says,
he's saying now that protest votes are a
waste.
Like what is he saying?
He told everybody vote for Hillary.
He told.
I mean,
he's not starting a third party and you
know,
his whole life,
he was like,
he said that we have to have the
verbiage he used.
One time I saw him was that,
uh,
you know,
Jesse Jackson's correct.
We knew we needed a rainbow coalition of
people,
uh,
but it has to happen outside of the
Democratic Party.
He said that that was him.
So we have to have a progressive
coalition,
but it has to happen outside and who
better to lead it.
But Bernie Sanders.
So that's why it's hard to start a third
party because you need people who are
already famous and popular and,
uh,
in government.
So if he left and he got saved,
Tulsi Gabbert and Nina Turner and
Alexandra Cause your court.
And he got a bunch of people that are
super popular on the left,
we'd have a third party and that would
be pulling at 10,
15 percent.
And now the Democrats would have to join
former coalition instead of what they're
doing now,
which is ignoring progressives.
After she cheated Bernie Sanders,
after the Democrats cheated Bernie
Sanders in the primary,
Hillary Clinton didn't choose Bernie
Sanders as their vice president,
as an olive branch.
Doesn't choose a little bit with worn as
an olive branch.
She went to her right.
She got Tim Kaine was to the right of
her.
Who's anti union,
whose.
Oh,
everything bad thing you want in the
Corporate Democrat,
he's pro walled.
The whole deal.
She went.
So just so if we had a third party that
actually pulled at 10 or 15 percent,
they would have to.
They couldn't do that anymore.
They'd have to.
They'd have to do a thing called Joe
voter outreach instead of voters shaming
or it's what it's devolved to now,
which is democracy shaming.
They're literally shaming people for
participating in democracy.
You don't get to participate in
democracy because you're a third party
will fuck you.
That's called democracy.
And so yes,
I do.
And I get to vote my conscience.
It will be right back.
That's good.
That break right there.
Solid going a radio show,
that will be the way to go.
Hey,
one of the reasons why we came in today
is because we wanted to talk about the
Alex Jones situation.
Um,
I know you were a notch as a vocal
critic of Alex Jones.
You spit in his face on,
on live Internet show.
I did not spit in his face.
That was completely involuntary.
He coughed and liquid came out of your
mouth.
As you know,
Alex Jones is hilarious.
There's no doubt.
There's no denying that.
He's occasionally very hilarious.
Yes.
Yeah.
And I told you what happened.
I was walking up.
He's having this,
they're just about to go fisticuffs the
whole time.
And as I walk up he goes,
Hey,
I'm just trying to be nice and you had
to spit.
And I had a mouthful iced tea and I
understand that's my story.
I'm sticking to it.
Good story.
You know who trump meant to say would I
would actually say would.
Yeah.
He actually,
what did he say?
I don't see any reason why they would,
but he meant to say what it's.
Yeah.
That was one of the worst lies I think
anybody's ever told on television in
front of millions of people.
That was a disturbing lie because in the
context of the words and the way he was
communicating,
it's very clear.
It's very clear.
He meant to say what
it meant.
It was disconcerting to me for different
reasons.
It was disconcerting to me because it
showed that he
mcadam to cave.
Yeah.
Someone talked to him.
Someone pulled them aside and said,
do you understand what the fuck is going
on here?
By the way,
when they go,
oh,
he did.
He,
uh,
trump contradicted our intelligence
communities in public in Helsinki,
and that's treason.
No ass wipe.
That's not treason.
The president sets our foreign policy.
You're not supposed to contradict the
fucking president.
Whatever the president says goes,
and I hate fucking saying this because
I'm not a fan of Donald trump,
but God damn it,
we all lose our head and think that the
unelected spies run our foreign policy.
They do not spice spice or spice
unelected.
Yeah.
So,
and the ones who let us into Iraq,
let's not forget that the very.
Do Anyway,
don't.
Do you ever play that video?
I played almost weekly on my show of
Robert Molar lying about weapons of mass
destruction to Congress to get us into
the Iraq war.
Well,
he was misinformed at the time.
He wasn't aware of all the information
and you know him along with Colin Powell
and many others where they're just good
guys,
good people,
good people to do it in a bad.
Those those no bid contracts at
Halliburton got for billions and
billions of dollars.
It's just because they were the right
ones for the job.
I mean,
why have bids when you've got
Halliburton and you've got a guy who's
really close to Halliburton and Dick
Cheney,
who used to be the CEO of Halliburton as
the vice president.
He got a sweet deal here.
Take advantage of it.
Halliburton gave Dick Cheney a
$30,000,000
down payment when he became vice
president of this little bit of that.
Trying to help you out.
I know you like to go duck hunting,
give you a nice gun.
Don't shoot your friend in the face.
That's how I used to do a bit about that
too.
He shot his friend in the face and his
friend,
apologize,
apologize.
That's how gangster Dick Cheney is.
Ah,
I should've been there or I looked like
a bird thing was so fucking crazy,
you know?
Um,
we were talking about Alex Jones being
the platform.
Yeah,
I mean,
it seems to be across the board,
like they're,
it's almost waited for apple.
It seems like when apple pulled them
from itunes,
then,
you know,
youtube,
uh,
danced with it,
right?
They'd given him some strikes.
It was really recently,
like within the last couple of that
facebook had given him some strikes and
Youtube gave him some strikes and people
are like,
hey,
you know,
there was some,
I felt like almost like unfounded,
um,
speculation
that they would remove him from the
platform.
My 10 navigant or move him.
That's crazy.
That's too far.
And then all of a sudden,
boom,
everybody in one fell swoop.
Spotify,
spotify remove him.
They were going to,
they did.
Itunes removed him.
But there's a loophole though that some
of you.
I saw an article today where people want
nothing less than total destruction.
Uh,
I,
that apple,
uh,
attacked Alex Jones and got rid of them,
but they offered him a safety net in the
form of the APP that he has on their APP
store that they're still.
So they were trying to take that down to
like take down his,
his show became instantly way more
popular.
Oh,
I'm sure.
So it can.
The unintended consequences.
I try to tell people that,
uh,
you know,
I'm not defending Alex Jones.
I'm defending,
you know,
the principle of freedom of speech.
You know,
people who are convicted of killers or.
No,
on death row,
they still get their freedom of speech.
You're allowed to print articles and
they're allowed to have,
you know what I mean?
They're still allowed to.
Oh,
he's allowed to still.
I mean,
he does.
He's hasn't been silenced.
He has his website,
but he could put his show out on his
website.
He can,
he can host it from his website and it
could all be fine,
but these major media companies now,
they just decided we've had enough.
We don't want this on,
and here's the thing,
like,
I don't know what he said that they
were,
there was the straw that broke the
camel's back.
It seemed like it's not a recent
statement that says go to the court
transcripts and we'll figure out.
Oh,
there wasn't.
There wasn't a,
Oh,
there is no hearing or nothing.
There wasn't a judicial hearing.
There was no.
Come on.
Do they just want,
they let some Jag off billionaire in the
middle of the night on a whim,
fucking do this.
Is that what happened?
Do you think that's what it is?
That was some billionaire or do you
think it's the middle managers and the
executives at all these giant tech
companies have just decided?
Um,
I don't know.
It's,
it's definitely,
uh,
the government tells facebook,
what to do a lot of times.
Right.
And so they bow to the government all
the time because they don't want to be
regulated.
So,
uh,
that's why they just,
they just started having hearings with.
That's why they had those hearings.
Should we regulate facebook?
So those hearings,
by the way,
we're fucking bizarre.
It was like a guy pretending to be
human,
you know,
it's like some sort of a robot or an
alien the way you would sip water.
He would take like this and it was like
a guy spitting dip into a glass.
He would go to.
It was the weirdest little sips.
Someone should make a compilation of
Zuckerberg,
sips of water.
Whoever is that guy who makes their
compilations of your show.
He does a good job as a funny job by
those Zuckerberg or pressure.
No senator.
No Sir.
There.
Watch this.
Watch that.
Sip.
Give me another one of those.
Oh,
there is one.
They have them.
Yeah.
Oh,
so there is a tricky water.
Oh my God.
Watch them sip who fucking sips water
like that.
It's like he has to think about it.
Act Normal.
Be Human.
Humans drink water,
drink the water.
Slowly he tilted that glass at him and
the guy behind him at the same colored
tie.
That's the guy that they're going to
shoot in the head keeping eye contact
while he was drinking the water.
It's kind of weird trying to at least be
disrespectful.
Fantastic.
That,
that whole thing was so strange.
It was so what a better guy to,
uh,
to,
to protect us from fake news and tell us
what's real news and you know,
who has integrity and what doesn't.
Then a guy who made a couple of billion
dollars off a stolen idea from his
friends.
I mean,
I think that's the perfect guy to say
that.
The true story.
Is that what he actually did he,
I think that's what was in the movie,
right?
That was in the movie.
That's what I know.
I didn't see the movie.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
I know the story though was that he
ripped people off that it wasn't his
idea,
but he was the one who figured out a way
to wrestle at a get rich as fuck.
But this is Matt Taibbi wrote an article
on this second,
August second about this and um,
there's been a lot of people being
platform from facebook that you don't
know about.
Like,
this isn't like,
uh,
okay.
So,
um,
here's,
here's what he's,
they shut down lots of other sites at
the behest of the government in Israel,
like the,
and the Atlantic Council.
So pages like black elevation,
they got shut down a page called mindful
being.
They got shut down.
A facebook also wiped out,
no unite the right to it,
which is a page appearing to advertise a
counter rally on the upcoming
anniversary of the violence in
Charlottesville.
So they shut that down to Matt,
how you beat it.
Let me just give you a quick quote from
his article.
He says,
facebook was helped in its efforts to
wipe out these dangerous memes by the
Atlantic Council on whose board you'll
find confidence inspiring names like
Henry Kissinger,
Cia,
chief,
Michael Hayden,
former acting cio,
had Michael Morel and former Bush era
homeland security chief Michael
Chertoff.
These people now have their hands on
what is essentially a direct lever over
nationwide news distribution.
It's hard though to state the potential
mischief that lurks behind this union of
Internet platforms and would be
government censors at Kennedy's.
Read you one more paragraph because this
is.
This is exactly what we're talking
about.
He says,
it is already a scandal that these
defacto private media regulators have
secret algorithmic processes that pushed
down some news organizations in favor of
others,
which they do witness the complaints by
outlets like alternate truth dig and
others that big platforms have been
deemphasizing alternative sites in the
name of combating fake news.
But this week's revelation is worse when
facebook works with the government and
want to want to be star chamber
organizations like the Atlantic Council
to delete sites on national security
grounds using secret methodology.
It opens the door to nightmare
possibilities that you'd only find in
Dystopian novels.
So he goes out and it's,
it's awesome what he says,
but I'm.
We would have more comfort if.
I mean,
there's no,
like one of the things that they're
doing is they use that blanket term hate
speech.
Yeah.
So by the way,
so now they're trying to put a bill.
Have you heard about this in Congress to
make police a protected class of people?
So if you say shit about them now it's
considered hate speech.
Did you know that?
Yeah.
They're trying to make peep.
Yes.
So fuck.
The police would be considered hate
speech.
So they would just retroactively arrest
Nwa.
They could not iced tea,
man.
Cop Killer.
Right motherfucking cop killer.
And so now if you do have a rally that's
against the police,
that's a hate rally and they can take
your youtube channel down if you said
hate stuff about the cops and such.
So.
So that that's where we are.
Hate speech.
The fuck.
How come I'm not allowed to hate shit by
the way.
I hate Nazi's.
Can I say I hate fucking Nazis.
I hate the KKK.
Can I say I hate them?
That's hate speech.
I.
You strongly disliked the KKK.
You can strongly disliked something.
When I was a kid,
I hated the fucking dodgers.
I know speech because I was a cubs fan
and the doctors always kicked out.
It's fish.
Yeah.
Hate speech is a strange blanket term.
Almost like drugs,
you know,
drugs is caffeine,
but it's also heroin.
You know,
it's like drugs.
What's wrong with it?
I don't understand what it is.
There's hate out there.
So what?
So what's.
So by the way,
I
bad way of expressing things like hate
speech is,
it's not a good descriptive because I
agree.
When you,
when you stopped the,
what does it entail?
Like you know,
I had a conversation with a woman at
Youtube about Sam Harris and I'm a
Douglas Murray and a podcast where they
had had a conversation and someone put
it on their youtube channel in their
playlist,
just put it in their playlist and they
got a community guidelines.
Oh,
I,
I asked why and the woman said very
cleanly it was hate speech.
And I said,
what are you talking about?
I go,
did you listen to it?
It was a two intellectuals to public
intellectuals discretion discussing
immigration and some of the problems
that Europe is having right now.
And you decided that that's hate speech
and you don't even know what they said
but that.
But the fact that she's so confidently
described it in that way sort of,
it sort of embodies what this problem
is,
is that they have these blanket terms.
There were other throw on problems and
there's a million other fires to put
out.
So there's no more needed to put any
more consideration to this.
This guy is a problem.
This is problematic.
This is hate speech.
Shut it down.
People don't realize how bad it is for
all you do because you know this story.
But people go,
Oh,
good for Alex Jones.
He shouldn't be able to do that stuff.
What?
He's doing that good.
I'm like,
do you not understand that this is the
shot across the bow,
that if they can do this to Alex Jones,
that they're coming.
I've already been trashed by the
establishment media,
by the Washington Post,
by.
I've already been equated to pedophiles
and those kinds of things and conspiracy
theorists and I been in articles with
Alex Jones.
They've done it to me.
So because I tell the truth about the
war,
right?
And so,
uh,
the antidote to bad speech,
if you really hate what Alex Jones is
doing,
the antidote to bad speech is not
censorship.
The antidote to bad speech is more
speech.
If you think,
if you think what Alex Jones is doing
needs to be debunked,
create a facebook page called debunking
Alex Jones and debunk him.
The old Kyle Kalinsky does that kind of
stuff all the time.
People do that stuff all the time.
That's how you convert.
If you're afraid of an idea,
you don't shut down the idea,
you expose the idea and you debunk it,
but if you have a private platform and
you own this and you start a business
and your businesses putting up youtube
videos and you decide that someone is
putting up something that's hurtful and
damaging and racist and it could be used
to attack large groups of people and
then you see like all the craziness
that's been connected to the alt right
movement and you associate that with
this individual.
Do you have to keep that on your
platform?
I mean there's no regulation right now.
No,
not like technic public utilities or it
should be though.
That's my point.
My point is that 70 percent of the
people get their news from Google and
facebook and they're a monopoly,
right?
So they had planned on ballistic powers.
70 present.
Yeah,
that's,
that was,
uh,
that was a stat I read today.
So you can't.
It's like,
well,
it's written that turn on and off.
I believe it.
Hey,
they took.
They took stretch.
Yeah.
They,
you think it's a stretch?
It's says 45 percent of the people get
straight from facebook.
That means $150.
Million people are on facebook every
single day.
Yeah,
I would think that's not accurate.
No,
but I think that's right.
But when they get their news,
we don't have three people in this room
aren't.
So that's three people right here.
They're aren't.
But I get my news from Google.
Good.
I have that Google App on my phone and
every,
every day I go to it in the morning when
I'm taking a shit and I go over like,
what's crazy today?
What's happening?
Oh,
new porsche coming out.
One sentence like Sacha Baron Cohen do
one sentence.
Let's see what they said.
I just looked at it.
It's what it said.
Forty five percent.
I get it from,
from a facebook ad to.
Is it a Gallup poll?
It was according to their stats and I
went back to read another rolling stone
article to find out.
Right,
and it's a bunch of like a facebook
article,
selling advertisements,
trying to find the data.
So even even,
even if you clip it with those,
we can't deny like Alex Jones cannot now
go,
well,
just go to the other youtube,
just go to the other facebook.
There isn't another.
So we have to recognize that the way we
are organized as a society,
that the town square is now owned by
corporations who that need to be
regulated.
Right?
Like before,
if you know when 18 t was the phone
carrier for everybody,
they couldn't go,
I'm not going to give Alex Jones a phone
service because I don't like the shit.
He's saying that.
So you know,
we,
you can't deny services,
somebody,
all that stuff.
That's not really a valid comparison
because the phone wasn't distributed
information to people.
The phone service is just a method of
communication.
It was just a utility.
What he's able to do through info wars
is if you've got them on your platform,
he's going to say some things and he's
going to use your platform to say some
things that you know,
might not be true.
It might be crazy.
So you've got to decide like when does
it become a problem?
And I think where they drew the line
with Sandy Hook.
So here's what I say,
Joe,
uh,
we need to treat these as public
utilities because they are right
facebook,
there is no alternative.
There is an alternative to youtube.
We need to deregulate them.
Well,
it's a long overdue by the way.
And they are monopolies.
We,
there's obvious to everyone that there
are monopolies,
but you know,
when you,
when you invent something called
whatsapp and then facebook buys it for
$20,
billion dollars,
there's a monopoly,
there's no way.
There's no way to,
to compete with these people.
So these are monopolies.
They need to be regulated and people's
need to be protected.
And it,
it,
that's how,
that's where we need to go because right
now we're leaving it up to the whims of
a billion.
Like you'd say,
Hey,
if Alex Jones really did some shit that
was wrong and he should be taken off,
or his free speech should be a bridge
for it,
do it.
Let's do it.
Go go to a court or go to a thing or go.
People go,
well,
he docks his people and he didn't.
I go is if doxing is illegal,
he should be prosecuted.
If that's what happened,
but you shouldn't take away.
Did he docs people?
That's what they're saying.
They're saying he's died.
He wanted he docs people from newtown or
whatever from the school shooting,
so that's what they're talked about.
The individuals that he gave their
addresses and their names.
That's what they are saying,
that he decay,
but let's find out if he actually did
that because that sounds crazy.
I,
I'm,
I don't know if he did,
but they're not saying what he actually
did.
This is what's crazy.
I keep hearing that he promoted the idea
that sandy hook was a false,
was false and that it was a false flag
and that these were all actors.
I don't know if he actually said that.
I think what he actually said was,
I don't know if that happened.
I think that's what he actually said.
People are saying,
well,
that's promoting the idea that it was a
hoax someone,
but I want to know if that's what he
really said.
See,
I don't know if that's even the case
because I've heard it.
I've heard it written that he promoted
the idea that sandy hook was a
conspiracy,
but I did not quoting.
When they say that there's no quotes,
there's no.
Sandy Hook was a hoax.
Those kids were actors.
Those kids are not dead.
I don't see that anywhere,
but they keep attributing that to him
without quotation.
But again,
if this.
If there was some kind of process due
process where you could go back and look
at the transcript.
No,
not only that.
If during this whole time where he's
being tried,
he was still labeled to be on youtube
and have his videos.
He could show in his videos that he
didn't say that he could show what he
actually said and tell you what he
actually said and show clips.
He can't do that anymore.
So now the narrative is completely in
the hands of the mainstream media,
100 percent.
So the Alex Jones narrative is being
taken 100 percent out of his hands and
now it's in the mainstream media and now
there's sandy hook denier,
conspiracy theorists,
right wing,
lunatic,
all these different things.
Which mayor,
if some of it.
I mean Alex my fucking nuts.
So my point is we've had nuts.
People would always tell that when I was
a kid,
Joe,
maybe you remember Johnny Carson used to
go ape shit about the national enquirer.
Yes.
Do you remember that?
And it was a big deal.
He would stop his show and I'm putting
my foot down about this.
They still have the national and nobody
said take it out of the supermarkets.
Nobody was like,
we've got a band in that newspaper
because we can't handle the ideas from
this newspaper that they're still right
there.
You go to Ralph's,
they're right there.
They're the last thing you see before
they leave.
They're right at the eye level for kids.
Nobody what says,
take away the national.
And I went to facebook.
They still have a facebook page.
Natural acquirer.
Yes.
So does the World News daily.
And you know what the first news news
story was that came up on world news
dailies was a British man can only
dedicate through his mouth.
That was the first story that came up.
The first story.
You don't have to look for it.
British man,
Devin.
Kate's through his mouth.
I'm like,
dude,
this is like South Park and it's not
like you want them to be taken down as
well.
But it's what's interesting is like
World News daily and
Star magazine,
all those,
they've sort of been there a joke like,
you know,
it's not real,
the enquirer is not real,
but we know that,
but it's not.
It's just finding those.
So.
But he's buying.
Are they buying the other kind of buying
somebody watches professional wrestling.
Here it goes,
lawsuit quotes,
Jones saying.
Yeah.
So sandy hook is a synthetic.
Completely fake.
Is,
is a thin synthetic.
Completely fake with actors in my view,
manufactured.
Okay.
I would show the visual,
right?
January 13th,
2015.
The lawsuit quotes Joan saying.
Yeah.
So Sandy.
So sandy hook is a synthetic,
completely fake with actors.
My view manufactured.
Yeah,
you that you actually nail that
impression.
I spent a lot of time with that dude
drunk.
If there's a.
he's.
I'm like,
that's,
that's a real problem saying something
like that.
It's crazy.
But he's,
he's look,
he,
his whole business is saying things that
are sometimes right and saying things
that are sometimes absolutely wrong,
you know?
And,
and that's.
And it's all wild and it's all
globalists.
And you ever seen that song that they
did with these guys?
Took his actual words and rants,
but then they have like this like emo
song singing the words.
No fucking genius.
Would we get pulled over off of Youtube
if we play that?
Let's find out if we get yanked for this
one because it's brilliant because it's,
it's a parody,
but it's so.
It's so deep.
Focus on.
Yeah.
He said he was fine enough.
There's two indie folk,
emo.
Just,
you know,
some low testosterone music.
Please listen to this.
Listen,
listen,
listen to this.
And that's why we're just doing simple
things.
Pointing out that we're meant to be a
nature natural and this is where we find
the source that God made your transcend
the new world order and that's why they
want to try to keep us out of it.
Factors keeping
what?
Taking audio out.
Oh,
you're taking the audio off.
Alex Jones rants as an indie folk song
for people that are just listening to
this.
You gotta Google this because we removed
the sound from Youtube.
Oh,
okay.
Babies.
We love.
Say we want to eat babies.
I have the video you just said could not
fill it.
Oh,
Paul and Hillary posts.
But like so far,
this is song literal Fab,
Pyre potbelly.
Come on.
Oh,
oh my God.
Uh,
you know,
I think there's something.
There's something about his struggle
right now that's representative of the
chaotic world that we live in,
that that he does have this giant voice
than he does is they have this giant
following and that it is this,
this is actual words come out in song
like that and are so hysterical and that
they think that somehow or another
yanking this guy off all these platforms
is gonna like remove it.
Do they understand the streisand effect?
Because this is just gonna.
It's going to be another way,
but what's the streisand effect?
Barbara streisand had a house in Malibu,
just giant ass house.
They took pictures of it and she went
ape shit and you know,
complained to all these newspapers and
complained to the police and everything
that they're taking photos of her house
and get the fuck Outta here.
This I'm Barbara streisand.
And because of that it became a giant
story that Barbara streisand is pissed.
If someone's showing her house and
they're like,
wow,
it must be a hell of a house.
Where is it?
And then there it is.
The effects is a phenomenon.
There's the house whereby an attempt to
hide remover sensor,
a piece of information,
unintended consequences of publicizing
the information more wildly,
usually facilitated by the Internet.
Okay.
Yeah.
No,
I thought you,
but on print,
again,
people may make the false equate.
Oh,
you're defending Alex.
Joe.
I'm not defending defending free speech,
defending free speech and I understand
the argument that,
hey,
it's a private corporation.
I get that.
But if you took a look at the bigger
picture,
the should beat.
Everyone thinks the internet should be a
public utility.
I mean,
most people do and that's what they're
upset that they're not treating it like
a public utility.
Obama administration did.
They decided to at the last minute.
And so if you think the Internet should
be a public utility,
I think youtube and facebook should be a
public utility also and but there's the,
there's an opening for other people to
make their own youtube,
like make a version of it if you have
them an efficient capital,
but you don't.
And there's some.
And if you do start it,
they'll just buy you out.
Like I just showed you the example of
whatsapp with nightwood,
$19,000,000,000
on whatever they paid for.
It was some crazy.
So that's a,
just eat up their competition right now.
We need to Teddy Roosevelt to come along
and break up all these monopolies.
It's never gonna happen.
Uh,
the end of the empire is coming.
So here's the question,
like,
is there a valid parallel,
a valid comparison?
Like are there people that have things
that are more hateful that are on
youtube that haven't been deep
platforms?
Is it the influence that he has that
it's terrifying?
Is it the fact that he's a figurehead
for this kind of stuff?
Is that what it is that he's the.
This whole info wars movement is in some
people's mind a figurehead for this pro
trump thing.
They're trying to stop and silence.
Like what is it?
I don't know.
It's very curious that it all happened
at the same time.
Right?
And because there's a,
there's a,
um,
in 1996 there was a law passed that
actually insulates the platforms for
being sued.
Did you know that?
So like for them.
So if someone puts up something like say
he puts something up that leads to
someone getting killed,
right?
On facebook,
you can't,
you can't sue youtube,
you can't sue facebook for it.
That's in that 1996 law.
Um,
so there's that.
So I get that they're a private company,
but again,
they have to have the protection of the
law.
They have congress protecting them.
So they have a certain.
That's a certain type of regulation
you're regulated from.
You can't sue them.
Right?
So I'm looking for this tweet bike,
Glenn Greenwald that really,
because if we're going to take down
here,
I'll find it.
Here it is.
He says there's been a tactic of sensors
for centuries.
They start with someone who was so
utterly hated and marginalized that
everyone is blinded by their hatred for
the first central ship target that they
cheer and forget that they're endorsing
a principle and power that will then
expand.
And so right now they came for the Jews.
Yeah.
Right now we're allowing,
uh,
the whim of billionaires in the middle
of the night to decide who gets to be on
these monopolistic platforms and who
doesn't.
If there was 10 youtube,
no one would care,
but there isn't.
There's one youtube,
there's one facebook and they are
monopolies and that's the world we live
in right now and that's why they are
doing whatever the government wants them
to because they don't want the
government to regulate them.
That's why he went there and was sipping
the water like that and trying to make
guide tat contact and be nice because he
doesn't want them to regulate them.
He'll do it for.
I'll do Julian assange and 2010 gave a
speech which I saw recently on a plane
where he predicted this.
He was like,
the corporations are an extension of the
government and they will do the
censorship in the future.
And that's exactly what's happening
right now.
So do you think is the government that
sensory Alex Jones,
because I would think that the
government that's in power currently
would want to keep Alex Jones and
position because he's a supporter of
trump.
He's a supporter of,
you know,
why does,
so why does,
why is trump going after Julian assange
just because he's afraid he'll expose
him someday.
I don't know.
Why is he allowing the CIA to do that,
to go after Julian assange and you know,
that just shows you how shitty the
journalists are in America because not
one of them are standing up for Julian
to signs and they're all pretending that
when trump says mean things about Jim
Acosta,
that somehow that's this unbelievable
violation of our freedom and our press
and he's got you son of a bitch.
You don't care if you cared about
freedom of the press.
You would say something about Julian
Assan and no one is saying,
what lie has Julian assange is ever
printed.
Never,
never,
never.
What did Julian assange's do?
He revealed that our election was being
rigged by the Democratic Party,
not Russia,
but by the Democratic Party.
And that is a sin you can commit.
You can not tell the truth about the
powerful.
And that's what's happening right now.
And uh,
you know,
he,
he revealed the CIA in has,
although spying techniques that they can
get your tv to listen to you,
your phone,
a vault seven,
all that stuff he revealed that's why
they want to get them.
But I trump,
you know,
I just think that trump is just,
he's not really clued in,
right?
He's,
lets other.
He's glad to let the generals do the job
and his underlings,
he doesn't really want.
He wants to paint broad strokes and lets
everyone you want to kill Julian.
Sounds.
Go ahead.
I don't give a f that's I think how he
feels.
I don't think it's his plan to do it,
but everybody else underneath it wants
to.
And certainly the intelligence community
and everyone forgets this.
Chuck Schumer went on Rachel Maddow show
like two years ago and right out in
public said that trump is making a
mistake by crossing the intelligence
community because when you mess with
them,
they have six ways to Sunday to mess
with you back.
Holy Shit.
And nobody cared that he said that.
So what he's saying is the president
should be afraid of unelected spooks,
unelected bureaucrats,
these don't.
They should be,
he should be afraid of them.
That is.
And no one went.
What,
what the apps could you imagine saying
that about Barack Obama?
Hey,
Barack Obama better be nice to the CA.
They're gonna to eft with him as an
elected official to official saying that
almost almost sanctioning it.
Yes.
And then we have Eugene Robinson and the
Washington Post or writing an articles
begging the deep state to undermine
about trump's foreign policy.
Did you see that article?
No.
Yes.
Pulitzer Prize winner.
First they spend all their life denying
there is a deep state.
And that new gene Robinson writes an
article begging the deep state to defy
president,
uh,
president trump.
So blinded by ideology that they don't
see the consequences of this.
There's unintended consequences.
And here they are and they're coming.
They've already come for me.
They're already coming for the left
third.
This is how,
this is how this works.
So again,
that's why I worn all my friends about
the Russia gate.
Nonsense Chomsky said,
if you care about the people meddling in
our election,
Russia would be the last place I would
look.
The first place to look is concentrated
capital.
That's what dictates who are going to be
our government.
That's why we don't have the things the
rest of the world has because we have a
cut.
Capital has captured our government,
which is why we don't have medicare for
all,
which is why we don't have free college,
which is why we don't have an
infrastructure plan,
which is why we're in a wars.
Meanwhile,
people have to countries poor or low
income.
Sixty three percent of the country can't
afford a thousand dollar emergency and a
quarter of all kids are in poverty in
the richest country in the world.
Joe,
what do you call a system that takes the
richest country in the world that
renders half of its population poor or
low income?
That's a failed fucking system and
that's what we're living in right now
and it's failing worldwide.
Now.
If you were someone like Google though,
or who owns youtube or if you were
itunes or any of these platforms that
have spotify when you get an
overwhelming volume of complaints about
someone who's in the news right now,
because the fact that Alex Jones is
being sued by the Sandy Hook parents,
this is what started this all off
because to people this is so egregious,
these poor parents lost their children
and here's this guy.
It's horrible saying that it's fake and
that they don't want that on their
platform.
So would you think that they should just
delete the episode that has that?
It says that,
should they do that or should they allow
that episode?
I,
so,
uh,
here's the,
here's the solution.
If,
if there's,
if he did do something in a video that
is illegal,
take that video down until it gets
adjudicated.
You don't see platform of 100,
you don't give him the death penalty.
Right.
So,
okay.
What about like stormfront,
what have you got?
Like some white supremacist group.
It's calling for violence against
people.
You Do,
you take them down.
I think you would.
Again,
you would have to,
I would like to see in some kind of
adjudication,
you know,
again,
I,
the blanket policies and things saying
things like hate speech.
It's all interpretation in bed.
Just a week ago,
Mark Zuckerberg was defending it.
He was defending that,
that we have holocaust deniers on our
platform,
holocaust deniers.
Joe,
and that's not fake news.
That's not going.
You're not going to take that down like
I just told you.
They have guys deprecating out of their
mouth.
They have this thing.
They have the,
the,
uh,
the national enquirer.
They're still cool.
So this is a very squiggly line.
Joe.
And again,
there's,
there's no board,
there's no adjudication.
It's not transparent
parents,
not rational either.
This is not a rational debate.
Uh,
let me just,
the sheer.
Let me just give you one more thing
about what he says when this is Matt
Taibbi.
He says,
the sheer market power of these
companies over information flow has
always been the real threat.
This is why breaking them up,
she'd have long ago become a national
priority instead,
as was obvious during the Senate hearing
with Mark Zuckerberg earlier this year,
politicians are more interested in using
then curtailing the power of these
companies.
The platform for their part will cave
rather than be regulated.
The end game here couldn't be clearer.
This is how authoritarians marriages
begin and people should be very worried.
They should be worried.
They should be worried,
especially if this does escalate.
I understand that people who believed
that he's a sandy hook deniers and they
read those words,
they don't want him to have a platform.
They don't want them to be able to
spread that hate and they understood.
I understand that they would feel like
imagine being one of those parents and
you lost your kid and you're,
you're.
You're seeing this guy on tv or on
youtube saying it's all fake.
It's,
it's outrageous and it's repulsive.
I agree.
It's offensive and I get that,
but I think it's,
it's,
it's very dangerous.
It's very dangerous to silence people
that may or may not have any other
recourse in terms of like he doesn't
have the ability to defend himself,
it doesn't have the ability to make a
video about it unless he puts it on his
own website and then who's going to
watch it like this,
the stuff that they're doing with
youtube,
it's just,
it's a slippery slope,
you know,
and especially when they use these terms
like hate speech,
they're not like when you say like what
do they say?
And they say that he violated their
terms,
correct.
Yes.
So what,
what are those terms that he violated
and what is the specific violation?
Like what are the words that he said
where you were like,
enough is enough.
If that's the case,
how did you let him get away with saying
all this other shit for years and years
and what,
when,
when do you draw this line?
Like just that video that we played,
you know,
they smell like sulfur,
they eat it,
they want to eat babies screaming.
I love Satan.
And the one of the babies like,
Whoa,
what?
Where does the line get drawn?
I just,
I don't,
I don't think.
I don't think that should be up to
subjectivity.
I think that should be a very,
very hard question that's answered with
very clear facts.
You
should have an adversarial judicial with
an impartial judge or jury.
And how would you even get someone
impartial instead?
They have inhouse decide decisions.
Well,
you heard that.
I mean you heard Matt Taibbi does
delineate the people who are involved in
this stuff and by the way,
facebook's taken down pages of people
who are Palestinians because the Israeli
government tells them to do it.
Do you know about that?
Right?
I had heard about it.
Yes.
So that's them doing the bidding.
The government says take a down,
take it you.
They don't get to free speech.
Okay.
Because I don't want the government to
get mad at me because we're making so
much goddamn money right now.
I don't want the government to get mad
at us.
That's what facebook and youtube is
doing.
See if I would like that.
If someone,
you know,
I'm not saying that no one should be
taken down.
If someone's calling for the death of
all black people and like maybe it's not
a good place to give them a platform,
but I feel like the problem that I'm
having with this is these things like
air quotes,
hate speech,
because I told you that they said that
about Sam Harrison Douglas Murray.
Now that is fucking crazy.
So when is it stopping hate speech?
Like when?
When do you draw the line?
When it's mildly offensive,
is that hate speech?
Like where's it go?
Where does it go?
Where we're not allowed to hate people.
I don't understand why I don't get that.
I'm not being a dick.
I honestly,
why aren't you allowed to hate things?
Right.
I don't.
I understand that calling for action I
think is the call for action might be.
I mean,
I guess it's a legal term that this is
not a legal term though.
The when they blanket things with hate
speech,
like we were saying,
was calling something a drug,
this is an illegal drug.
Well,
what if caffeine becomes an illegal drug
then?
Is that the same as meth?
It's clearly not.
There's different things.
So when you say hate speech and you also
lumped Douglas Murray having an
intellectual conversation with Sam
Harris about immigration,
you lump that in.
So that's the kind of soft.
And so did you know that right before
fourth of July there was a newspaper,
I think it was in Texas.
And so they wanted to for the fourth of
July,
they wanted to post the declaration of
independence.
So they posted the first half of it.
Did you know about this?
Facebook gave him a strike for hate
speech,
hate speech.
They gave him a strike and so now
they're like,
they were like,
that was an algorithm though,
right?
They picked up some of the phrase or the
phrasing in there about slavery and
stuff like that.
And then being animals or something like
that.
I don't know,
something like that.
I'm not sure what it was.
But.
And then the newspaper said,
now we're afraid to post the second half
of the declaration because we'll get a
second strike and they might pull our
whole page.
Yeah.
So again,
when they released that strike.
Correct.
So,
so yeah.
So what is this book?
Pill?
What is this idea that I need a nanny
state to protect me from the ideas?
I think they're worried about the power
of propaganda and it's just they don't
know exactly what the consequences of
suppressing that power of propaganda
are.
I think that's really the primary issue.
They're worried that a guy like Alex
Jones already has this massive following
his what he's done by calling sandy hook
fake may,
may be awful,
I believe is,
but
is it enough to completely diy platform
him and how?
How are they,
how are they?
Even if it was,
let's say it was,
let's just say you and I agree that it
is okay.
They shouldn't.
Shouldn't there still be some kind of a
process?
There should be.
That's what I'm saying.
It shouldn't be.
Even if we agreed,
and again,
I hate that.
I hate it as much as you hate it,
I'm with you and that people are going
to.
I know Joe,
last time I was on your show,
I said,
I said people are going to take what I'm
saying right now and twisted and that's
exactly what they did to me last night.
So I'm sure people did who took it and
twisted it.
I don't want,
you don't have to name names,
but what did they do?
They say they twisted what we were.
So when we're talking about seth rich,
they twisted and I said,
you know,
I did,
was covered on my show until this day.
People still say I was pushing it.
I do a new show.
I covered it,
but even discussing it and even you
can't even discuss like I couldn't cover
it,
couldn't discuss it and that.
And so that's exactly what happened.
Somebody cut me saying that and cut some
other stuff and put it together.
And I was like,
son of a bitch.
But you,
so what are you going to do?
Right?
So what are you gonna do?
So,
um,
so I just want people to know this is
again,
I'm just as offended as everybody.
I'm saying we need to have these things
be public utilities for a lot of
reasons.
And that,
um,
you know exactly what Matt Tie.
He'd be said what the end game here is
very clear and they want to be able to
censor people.
They want to be able to censor and the
first people are going to come after his
left wing organizations.
They're could come after black lives
matter.
They're connected,
already come after left.
He's like,
why did they think they're going to come
after to black lives matter?
What do you mean there?
I their hate speech against the police.
You kidding me.
They already said they're controlled by
the Russians.
Who is they?
Who is they saying that and who's they
gonna come after them.
What do you mean by that?
So.
Well,
the FBI will infiltrate them.
They are,
I'm sure they already have,
you know,
how that works.
So you know,
how all that stuff works.
So that's how that stuff works.
And um,
and then just credit them and then they
will commit violence in their name and
say,
oh look,
black lives matters are violent.
No,
that was a cop doing it,
you know,
that didn't help that.
That's what happened up in Dapple,
you know,
that's the kind of stuff they do up
there.
And then provocateur.
Exactly.
Right.
So by the way,
I learned about that from Alex Jones.
So that's the problem with Alex Jones.
He's right about stuff sometimes.
Well,
he was way more right about stuff in the
past.
Alex himself and I've talked to him
about this,
says he drinks too much and he's getting
too crazy.
It needs to go on a diet and exercise
and start getting his life in order and
he takes things too far sometimes and he
should take those off the rails.
He goes off the rails like he.
He and I had a conversation,
but he got mad at me for saying that I
didn't think George Soros was a Nazi and
so he had this whole thing.
We ranted ray and then we talked back
and forth and he apologized and he said,
I sometimes have to far what I'm talking
to.
Aliens will say that unit,
but I think he recognizes that sometimes
he's just caught up in that cycle of
outrage,
that cycle of outrage.
It just,
there's no room for error.
There's no room to step back and sort of
reset is.
It's this constant outrage constantly
under attack.
And then there's these words that get
thrown around that sort of lose their
meaning,
like globalists and shills and,
and,
and you know,
and this,
this sort of attitude that there's this,
there's this cabal of evil that is
trying to take,
take over the world.
And at one point Alex had this idea that
they were going to try to kill off most
people and you remember that.
I heard about it.
There's this idea that they wanted to a
youth and I orj was genocide.
They wanted to,
they wanted to break it down to what is
the word where they talk about doing
that to talk about reducing the
population.
There's like some sort of a conspiracy
theorist,
term of reduction of population to a
sustainable number of super evil
geniuses that could live forever.
And they wanted to get it down to like,
you know,
500 million people worldwide that can
live for a million years or some crazy
shit.
But I think that that's that whole cycle
of like constant outrage and
everything's a conspiracy and you get
whacked,
whacked out and caught up in it.
If you go back to Alex's earlier videos,
I met Alex in 98 I believe,
and back then Alex was,
he was going after George w dot Bush
when George W dot Bush was running for
president and he was saying that this
guy is a,
he's a,
he's a puppet and that he's a puppet of
the CIA and you know,
and,
and he,
you know,
he supports genocide and he was showing
up at campaign rallies and they were
arresting him.
He was anti right wing.
I mean he was,
he was anti what he thought was this
globalist agenda.
He also infiltrated Bohemian Grove when
everybody thought the Bohemian Grove is
nonsense.
There's nothing really going on.
He's like,
no,
these really rich people are getting
together with heads of state and foreign
dignitaries and they're dressing up like
fucking druids.
And they have an effigy that they burned
in front of the owl God Molek and people
like,
he's crazy.
Then he releases the video and like,
oh my God,
they really do do that.
Like he did some good work.
The World Trade Organization protests in
his,
his video nine slash 11,
a road to tyranny right after nine slash
11.
He releases this video that shows that
the World Trade Organization protests
were infiltrated by these agent
provocateurs who are most likely
government agents with government agent.
Boots on,
by the way,
shows this in the video.
They smash windows.
They're all wearing masks,
had light things on fire.
Then they're all.
They all hold up in one house.
They negotiate with the police and are
eventually released.
This is all done under.
I mean he proved all this.
He showed all how this is going like,
look at these peaceful protesters.
Then the consequences of that,
they established a no protest line at
the WTO where you couldn't go by with a
pin on have you tried to get through
with a that said,
w t o with a red line through it.
They told you you could not wear that
pin.
You can't come through here.
This is a node protest zone,
and he's like,
this is the consequences of this kind of
censorship and this is how they
establish the censorship.
They make it seem like your organization
is violent and dangerous by introducing
violent,
dangerous elements in the,
in the form of an undercover police
officers or military.
They smash windows tip over newspaper
stands and it was fucking create chaos
so that the government has to come in
because now we have a violent situation,
so then the military comes in and arrest
protestors and silences the protests so
they don't look embarrassing in front of
all these people from foreign countries
that are coming here to the World Trade
Organization.
I didn't know he showed that,
but dude,
he look,
he's not wrong always,
and he was more right back then.
He was also more sane back then.
His,
he was more measured and more calm.
It wasn't this.
He didn't have the big moon face back
then either and he wasn't drinking as
much.
I don't think in the screaming and
spitting and and you know,
you ask him,
he'll say,
well,
I'm just overwhelmed by the sheer volume
of corruption,
all the shit that he sees every day.
Do you remember he was crying when trump
bombed Syria?
He was crying because he was crying that
trump fucked us.
You know what I mean?
He,
I really genuinely believe most of the
time that he means.
Well,
the,
the thing is we look for conspiracies
everywhere,
like everything that's experiencing
you're off track and I don't think
there's anyone there that can sit down
and go,
stop,
hold on.
Let's examine this in a factual way.
Let's stop.
Cut The hyperbole out and let's look at
what the facts are and where are we
getting these facts and why do we think
this is happening?
Why do you think this is fake?
Because that sounds fucking crazy to me.
No one's there to do that.
If someone was there to do that,
I think he probably would be stopped and
would examine things.
It would balance out,
you know,
like one of the reasons why I wanted to
have him on my podcast when I did was
because I wanted people to see the Alex
that I know because people like,
how could you know that guy?
I'm like,
look at how he is when I get them high
and we get drunk and he's laughing about
stuff and talking about interdimensional
child molesters and all that.
This is what I wanted everybody to see.
Like this is Alex Jones.
He's a fun guy.
It's just that,
that is not a good position to be in
where you're constantly looking for
conspiracies everywhere you go.
And you might nail a few,
but then you might call out a bunch of
them that are fake,
which not just negates the ones that you
nailed but negates everything you say as
soon as you're one of those guys that
everything's a conspiracy and then dead
kids aren't really dead and everyone's
an actor.
And like everything that you say that
it's good,
they're going to stop.
My uh,
thing is that I focus on the ones that
are important,
right?
That I think is right.
I'm like,
I don't,
I care about wars and the lies that are
told about wars from the media,
which the media pushes every war in my
lifetime.
So that's the ones I care about.
I hear everything you're saying.
And um,
yeah,
I don't,
I didn't really know.
I got to say God,
I didn't really know much about Alex
Jones until the,
I met him,
you know,
very famously at that incident,
I didn't really,
I never really watched them.
I went home that night.
I watched some of his videos,
which is when I found out some of them
are really funny and uh,
so I,
honest to God,
I didn't really know much about him and
so I don't even know this stuff.
So
if you could find that Jamie CV,
did they pull all that stuff from
youtube?
Everything but doesn't so else have it
probably on their channel.
And I did,
I never did videos about him or
debunked,
but I just,
you know,
it just,
he wasn't in my sight line of sight.
I was busy making fun of MSNBC and CNN.
That's what I like to do.
Yeah,
it's,
it's all very confusing to me and all.
I don't think he should say those
things.
I don't think he should say lies about
kids not being dead.
The,
the,
the horrors of being a parent and your
kid was shot.
And school shooting and then some guy
saying that there are 100 percent actors
and fake and lead.
That's horrible stuff.
There's a guy who was one of the parents
that was a conspiracy theorist until
this happened,
you know,
he was a conspiracy theorist.
He believed all that stuff.
And then his son was killed and then
they started calling him a fraud and
saying he was an actor and saying it
never happened and that he's a paid
shill and you know,
and there's a big article about this,
this guy.
I mean you see this guy talk and it's
heartbreaking.
You know,
you read his words,
it's heartbreaking.
You can imagine your son was murdered in
one of the biggest school maskers ever,
if not the biggest.
Right?
And here's people running around,
emailing you and sending you tweets and
facebook messages that you're a fraud.
And then you,
you know,
you work for the globalists and this is
all just a plot to take our guns away.
It's like holy.
These things are.
That's the people who think the old
school shootings that they're all set up
to so they can take our guns away.
They think that about everything.
They thought that about the country
music festival shooting in Vegas because
they felt like,
hey,
here's a way to get those people on our
side because those are all the second
amendment people,
the country music people.
What better people to get to turn
against the second amendment that a
bunch of people that are.
I mean I guarantee you if you had like a
red light that went off every time,
like on the top of someone's head,
if there were a national rifles agency,
if they were an NRA member in that
audience,
I bet there'll be a lot of fucking
lights a,
but a lot of those people are nra
people.
Lot of people who are gun owners.
I better just gun owners.
How many people are gun owners?
A bit fucking half.
At least half the audience.
Probably one of the strongest
demographics.
You could find.
Country Music,
gun owners.
That's a.
that's a giant connection and so the
thought was,
hey,
if this guy,
okay,
they make this Manchurian candidate and
make them gun down all these people,
some people think you didn't even do it.
They think they shot in the room and
then the agents did it and they killed
all these people and then there's
bullets coming out.
All these different windows and all
these different areas and like,
oh my God,
fuck it.
You know,
it's exhausting.
It's exhausting and it's also horrific,
man.
I mean the whole thing's horrific.
The idea that they think that the
government would create a false flag
that by the way didn't do anything
second amendment still in place,
but that they would create a false flag
and they would be willing to gun down
what did that he killed like 50 plus
people and shot like 500 something
fucking insane like that,
that,
that would be the,
that that's they would get together and
go,
you know,
we gotta do we gotta get this guy and
get them,
get them to shoot all these people and
that's how we're going to get rid of
guns is totally ineffective.
It hasn't done anything.
No.
A lead here.
Here's the thing,
and I'm not the first person to make
this point about guns,
is people who are big,
strong second amendment.
People say that.
Why?
Because whenever I advocate for gun
control,
people say,
oh good that only the governor will have
guns,
which is,
it's not a bad argument,
right?
It's not.
I,
I understand that argument.
Uh,
but the whole point of view keeping your
guns to protect yourself from the
government is that the government's
going to take your rights away.
So you need to have your guns to protect
your rights.
Well,
the government already took your rights
away.
They're already reading every email.
They're already reading,
listening on every.
You already lost your right to privacy.
They let you keep your guns while they
took the rest of your rights away.
So now you still have your guns.
Now why don't you go get your rights
back?
You have your gun that they're never
going to do it,
right?
So already report was an interesting
take on that,
right?
Like the,
the one day technology to reach a point,
you know,
for them it was like through those
little psychic dudes that um,
we're going to be able to predict future
crime.
Right.
And then he arrested you for a future
crime.
Yeah.
[inaudible].
That's kind.
Well,
they already cut.
Yeah.
They kind of do that.
Now they can arrest you for a conspiracy
to commit.
Okay.
Crime.
But you don't even have to have a crime,
right?
You just have some emails,
talk and shit.
I,
you get to have a role playing thing
that you do with your wife.
We talk about,
you know,
listen to you and I,
we're Bonnie and Clyde and we're going
to take down the government and they
just fucking kick down your door in the
middle of the night.
Yeah.
What's that?
Who's that comic?
Who had the ice agents breakdown?
That guy.
I started following him after that.
He made a joke.
Yeah.
What was the joke?
Oh,
I forget.
But that was fun.
That's pretty funny by the way,
to.
That guy's pretty funny.
I do know my phone.
I forgot that story.
He tells us hilarious about those ice or
the ice cops coming into his place.
What is his name?
Jake Jake parttime,
standup comic podcast hosts and
self-described pizza delivery guy,
who in a strange twist of fate recently
found himself debating immigration
policy with for homeland security agents
in his home.
The agent's paint him in early morning
visit last Sunday because of some jokes.
He tweeted about Cinco de Mayo.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is what he said.
Here's how Cinco de Mayo works in 2018
white people allowed to culturally
appropriate on the condition that you
helped destroy ice.
You kill one ice agent.
You get to wear
some barrel to kills you.
Get to wear a Poncho.
But the problem is that you can't joke
around about killing an agent because
there's,
you know.
So if he had a Sirius xm radio show,
he'd be fired right now.
Oh yeah.
Well they fired Nick Depaulo for that,
for saying something very similar to
that.
And so I say about that.
It's like,
so nick can't make a joke about someone
going into a university,
go,
hey,
next school shooter.
That was his joke.
Next,
the professor,
please go to the Berkeley and go to the
teacher's lounge or something like that.
Right.
Which everyone knows.
It's obviously a joke.
He's a goddamn comedian.
Jesus,
he's a right wing community.
Can we see everybody?
So,
so,
but you can go on those same radio shows
and they'll same radio stations and you
can advocate for killing hundreds of
thousands of people in another country
that you don't know and nobody says shit
all the time.
People do that.
People lie about.
So that's the.
That's the weird thing,
you know,
we can have a torture program in
America.
Nobody goes,
you know,
it's just weird that the.
And then the media goes along,
they don't even call it torture.
They call it enhanced interrogation
techniques because we're doing it.
But Nick said that that's all of a
sudden.
So it's just such a weird squiggly
bullshit line of morality and,
and so and now Nicole would be better
off for it anyway.
Yeah.
Nick will be better off for it and he
has a podcast now,
but I think unfortunately he's doing a
subscription service,
which I tried to talk all these guys out
of because you can't hear it at all for
free.
You have to pay and I don't know,
but it limits a bad idea.
Yeah,
it limits your growth.
I mean,
he's a famous comedian,
so I'm sure he'll get some money and I
know he's probably doing really well
with it,
but it's just.
It's impossible to grow.
Is it a subscription service?
Jamie's shaking his head on Patriot for
10 bucks or more.
He doesn't give you more.
So start at 10 and then keep adding
more.
So now all we do is we need to give all
the way all our stuff for free,
except we do a couple of weeks.
We'd maybe do a couple extra hours a
week for our patrons.
That's like bonus,
right?
So you don't,
but you don't want to.
That's not the worst thing in the world.
I just think that people have different.
You do bonus stuff.
No,
no.
Everything's free.
You're really lucky.
Your super,
super popular.
Yeah,
but when I wasn't super popular it was
all free too.
Yeah.
I had it free in the beginning when I
was getting a thousand downloads.
It's always been free.
I just.
I just want to just start to kick it.
Kick in for you.
When did you started to take off this
show?
Two years ago.
Three years ago,
something like that.
Really say about two years ago.
Three years ago.
Was it an issue or what is it?
You had a special guest that.
What was it you think?
I don't know.
It's momentum.
Just over time.
Just,
just always.
Just constantly doing it.
Grinding,
being in here,
delivering on three or four days a week.
Yeah.
You,
you do your best.
Do your best.
Get better at it.
Make mistakes,
apologize for your mistakes.
Keep going.
Because when I.
When I did your show last time,
I just in my head ever since like I
always like you are doing what I want to
do.
Like you don't.
I loved what I go,
Joe Doe because
people always try and discredit men.
No,
know how I got into a position where I
have to worry about being discredited.
I'm a fucking nightclub Jaguar comedian
and afterward,
that's why you're like,
I don't have to cage fighting.
I spoke the pod.
I'm not a reputable person.
I was like,
I want to be.
You want to be who I want to be.
I'm at a reputable person,
go fuck you.
You know,
I do my best to be honest.
I mean,
I approach issues and in an honest way,
but I'm not your source of reason,
but you know what I mean?
I'm not,
I'm not that guy.
I want to be a provocateur.
I want to be the guy in the outside
throwing spitballs that's,
that's who I want to be doing.
I am doing that.
Somehow I got caught up in this thing
where people are going to try to
discredit you.
Goddamn it.
It's so.
I'm confused.
I'm confused by this,
this Alex Jones thing,
because although I don't support a lot
of the things that he said,
I don't know why more people don't think
that this could be a real problem,
that they could just throw that hate
speech blanket on things and if I didn't
have that experience of talking to that
woman was,
she was describing the Douglas Murray,
Sam Harris' podcast,
which doesn't have a single slur.
It is no hateful rhetoric mean.
It's not hate speech.
I listened to it.
It's just a description.
I mean it's,
it's a discussion rather.
So you have that insight.
I know.
I know how calmly and confidently she
said it's hate speech.
It was like,
you know what it was like,
do you remember those old commercials
where um,
there was a guy and he was eating with
another guy and he was saying that if
you buy drugs,
you support terrorism.
Yes.
Like what do you mean?
He's like,
it's a fact.
It's just a fact.
If act fact and he's eating a salad,
he's a no nonsense guy.
Fact honey,
what do you mean its effect?
Its effect.
If Act fact,
you buy pot,
you're supporting terrorism,
but it's basically what you said.
It's hate speech.
It's basically the same sort of self
righteous indignation.
Yeah.
Where she didn't,
but when I was pressing her on it,
it was almost like she was my boss and I
couldn't talk to her about.
I'm like,
I don't work for you.
Do you understand that this kind of,
this method of communication that you're
accustomed to,
this does not apply here you.
You have to.
You have to discuss these ideas.
I want to know the merit of your
thoughts.
You know,
I want to see where you,
where your thought process laws that you
could just throw this hate speech
blanket on things and it turns out there
was no thought and there was no
consideration.
There was no examination.
She didn't know the content of the
conversation and her confidence in
saying that it was hate speech was
merely towing the company line.
The same company line that got James
Damore fired for the Google memo.
You know,
you,
you talked to actual evolutionary
biologists and people understand
psychology and people who are clinical
psychologists will talk to you about the
real differences between men and women.
Would he actually said in these
documents where he's.
He didn't make some sort of a
quantitative like like a ruling that
women are less valuable or that women
are worth less money or that women are
in somehow in any way,
shape or form inferior.
He simply wrote about clinical studies
that have shown tendencies to gravitate
towards different professions and even
had a page and a half in that about how
there's ways that we could encourage
more women to get into tech,
so it was.
It was not negative in any way towards
women,
but I saw all these people describing it
as hateful rhetoric and then that it was
reinforcing harmful gender stereotypes.
Like what with actual studies,
actual studies of science.
Those are real.
These are harmful gender stereotypes
because they don't add up to your vision
of Narnia diversity that you did that
only exists in Wakanda and some cloud
somewhere that you.
You've.
You've put up.
These are not real numbers.
There's reasons why people gravitate
towards certain professions.
Some of them are cultural,
some of them are biological.
They're fascinating to study,
but it doesn't mean that a person who
becomes a nurse is any better than a
person who becomes a carpenter or vice
or a guy who becomes a surgeon is any
better than someone who becomes a
computer coder.
This is not what anyone's saying.
What they're saying is there's reasons
why people find different things
interesting and some of them might be
the amount of testosterone they have in
their system and the fact they have x,
y chromosomes,
their their genetic history that the
history of their family and the culture
that they grew up and there's all these
variables and these variables are
fascinating,
but as soon as you say that,
these variables must even out at the
end,
we must have an equality of outcome
based on gender,
based on race.
Well,
you're not even talking about people
anymore.
Now you're just talking about something
that you need to say in order for you to
keep your job because you want to keep
collecting ones and Zeros and you
understand that there's this confusion
as to why there's not more women that
are leaders.
Why there's not more women that are in
tech.
Why there's not more this.
More that.
Why don't you really want to concentrate
on diversity.
You really want to concentrate on a
fairness concentrated why they're trying
to keep agents out of Harvard.
How about that?
Because that's some real fucking racism
that's going on right now.
No one's saying a word about it because
it's about people that are kicking ass.
They're kicking ass too hard,
so they're trying to.
They're trying to make it more
difficult.
There's a giant class action lawsuit.
Asians are suing Harvard because it's
more difficult for them to get in than
anybody else.
Well,
when I was a kid,
I was told that they pee,
pee in your coke,
and that's the Chinese show.
Now I grew up.
I know that's bullshit.
That's just a thing that they would tell
us.
Little Kids,
little kids.
Just say that that's all it is,
but it's like Joe St Joe to,
to the Charles Murray chat with the.
The antidote to that isn't to censor
them.
The antidote to that is good speech.
More speech wasn't even if you wanted to
be whatever is person to put it on their
playlist,
which is crazy.
Somebody got a community guideline
strike for putting it on their playlist.
I,
that's why I say we need to have it be
the youtube,
facebook.
These are public utilities.
They need to be regulated and there's no
way.
There's no getting around it.
Right.
They have super control in our culture.
They have massive impact.
But so to CBS.
Right.
So if you say something and CBS fires
you,
is that illegal?
Isn't it funny that Les Moonves is
getting in trouble for some he did to an
actress instead of in the eighties?
Yeah.
And instead of him being a long time
ago,
was it the eighties?
I think it was at least 20 years ago.
So 1996 with the one.
Oh,
was it?
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's still a long time.
Yeah.
So the eighties was,
um,
I'm sorry,
that was confusing that with your,
you're thinking of Sylvester stallone.
No,
I wasn't thinking.
I was thinking as George.
Oh,
George Psychiatry,
some guy popped out from the 85,
said he grabbed his deck,
like,
Hey,
let it go buddy.
Jesus Christ.
You know,
it's uh,
it's also,
it's not the,
you know,
there was a molester at my church.
We had a priest that was a molester
named father hollow.
Shocker.
Wait a minute.
Is it a Catholic Church?
Shocker.
What the fuck man,
you can't trust anybody.
And the kids,
we used to call them happy hands Holahan
because he would always cry because
whatever you come up,
he'd always like to wrestle you.
But he was the last kind of guy.
He was a nerd.
He was,
he was,
he's not a wrestling type guy,
but he wasn't a rapist trying.
He'd always come up like,
hey,
how am I?
Like,
why are you doing?
You're just trying to grab me.
And so we would call them happy hands,
Holihan,
and we would get in trouble if,
if they,
if our parents heard us that don't get
disrespectful to be like,
you know,
he's grabbing our dicks.
So they finally,
they finally caught him and I don't know
why I started talking about this,
but uh,
yeah,
why did I start talking about this?
And I know because we're talking about,
I always,
we always had,
we always thought it was like it was up
to you to not get molested by him.
Like if you got costs and we would
laugh.
We would laugh at kids who got caught at
it,
got less kids.
So we got to run faster.
Fucker.
He would take,
he would take us.
He had a,
a summerhouse right with a boat and up
in Wisconsin,
right.
So he would take us and it was like an
hour and a half away.
We get in his station wagon,
he take like six boys up to there and
we're going to go water skiing or
whatever.
Right.
And um,
so he had the day setup where he,
once you got there,
you had to first do cleaning,
so you had to change into your cleaning
clothes and.
Yeah.
Oh Jeez.
And so every time we had to go into the
room and change,
he would find a reason to come into the
room and wrestle one of us.
Oh God.
And then.
But we were like,
all right,
we got to put up with it because we want
to go onto the boat,
you know,
we were poor.
Oh my God,
poor.
You know,
we grew up.
Isn't it funny how it's only funny if
it's you,
like you're allowed to laugh about
getting to last as long as it's,
you know,
like no one could say like,
you like,
he.
Well,
he,
Jimmy was on the Joe Rogan show when he
was laughing about child molestation.
Oh my God.
Was that,
is that true?
Eight speech.
Put the blanket on it.
Hate speech.
But no,
it was,
he was,
he was talking about him getting
molested.
Well,
he's normalizing sexual assault.
He would take us.
This priest would try to teach you how
to ski.
Know How do you teach someone how to
water ski?
You put your Dick in their mouth for
your Dick in the mouth.
Do you know how to breathe under water
now?
Hold your nose.
No spitting.
So he,
the way you teach them what a water
skis,
you put water skis out and then when
they sit there on the dock and you pull
away,
right?
Uh,
and that's how you learn.
So he would take us in shallow water and
then he would go,
it would put the skis on you so you
couldn't run away from him.
And then he would like put his hands.
He would put his hands underneath your
crotch like this from to pick you up.
And then he goes,
now when the boat pulls it's gonna,
pull you up like this and it's going to,
it's good that jerk you off and the only
way to kill you gotta catch it in your
mouth.
And so it was a fuck man.
And so we looked at it like it was your
job to get out of that situation.
If you got caught,
we all laughed at you.
I remember my friend,
my friend Danny,
he's in the,
he's in the shallow water and he's
gotten off the boat,
pulls you,
and he goes like this,
and Danny looks at his dad and he goes,
he goes in front of everybody and we're
laughing,
laughing.
Now.
Did he actually molest anyone other than
inappropriate touching,
molested people?
Oh boy.
He had to leave the church and all that
stuff.
He believe the church that he's moving
moved.
He went to Arizona for a sabbatical.
Yeah.
He's.
He needs our prayers that this.
They sent out a note,
a letter to everybody's house and who
was in the poof.
You gave money.
They give you a letter.
Did hear no evil.
The documentary where they,
you know,
there was one priest that benedict who
became the pope moved who went onto
molesta hundred deaf kids.
Oh No.
Yeah.
Horrific.
Horrific Shit.
That,
that,
that process of moving people was always
terrifying because they basically let
them know,
hey,
you're not even going to be punished for
this.
We're just going to move.
Yeah,
just gonna move you.
we do.
Yeah,
it doesn't.
I know it.
I don't understand aerifying terrifying
stuff.
Yeah.
Why isn't the FBI infiltrate the
Catholic Church?
Yeah.
Imagine I,
I did a joke about onstage while back,
it was like,
imagine if that many nascar drivers were
fucking kids.
How quick would they shut down Nascar?
Nascar pulled into town,
just fucked all the kids and drove
around in a circle real quick.
They'd be like,
we gotta shut this down.
This is a crazy organized,
but meanwhile way more people getting
molested by the Catholic Church.
I,
I couldn't agree.
And it's a terrifying
number when you look at the numbers of
people that have just accused them of,
of sexual assault and molestation.
It's terrifying.
Yeah,
it's terrifying.
And now the money they take that you
give them on Sunday to go pay these
people off is also.
Yeah.
I feel very fortunate that I ducked
that.
I got lucky.
What was that?
A Catholic school you went to Catholic
school for one year.
Only first grade.
I was gone after first grade and uh,
you know,
I had friends that stayed in,
I know new people that got touched,
you know,
it's just,
it's,
it's for people who outside the Catholic
faith,
people who are.
There's something that happened and it
probably happened when they told them
they couldn't get married anymore
because it used to be the pope could get
married.
The pope was allowed to have children
and that priests were allowed to be
married.
Priests were allowed to have children,
but they were rock stars.
You have to realize like back in the
Lutheran days,
the days of Martin Luther and those,
those guys were fucking everybody.
They would get you in that confession,
in the confession with him,
what you did to Delores,
Delores,
they're just sucking dicks all day has
shown me I sucked at Dolores when they
were banging everybody and then they
came up with some sort of a reason why
they should have to be celibate.
And from then on,
well,
so here's what happened.
Here's what I heard was what happened
was that.
So there was two ways to become nobility
and the Bonnyville Times.
You could be born noble or you could buy
your way into the church and so you
could become nobility and so what would
happen is these rich motherfuckers who
would buy the witness of the Church
would die and then all their money would
go to their kid.
Their first born in the church is like,
we've got to get some.
We got to get our hands on that money.
And so they passed the law.
Hey,
nobody can get married legally.
They all did.
They still had kids and shit and they
still had mistresses and whatever,
but when they died,
all their money and property went to the
church.
That makes sense.
And so of course it's all about.
But.
So that's the story I heard.
If,
if anybody heard different levels,
it's both a bed,
it's a bed.
It had something to do with sex as well
and preventing those guys from fucking
everybody you know,
because they were rock stars.
There was no rock stars back then.
So the guys that were the spokespersons
for God would most likely be the ones
who had the most influence in the
community.
I mean,
he's a kid that we went to school with
who was a clearly gay and a nice guy and
he was going to become a priest when we
were all in high school together.
So as we were like riding the bus,
going to high school,
he was a couple of years ahead of me and
he was a leaving school and he was
already on his way.
What does it divinity school or
seminary,
anything.
Yeah.
He was on his way and we were all like,
we're all calling him father already and
it was just ridiculous.
We're all accepting the fact this guy
was going to be a priest,
but you know,
for him it was.
He was so obviously gay that,
you know,
I mean,
I didn't give a shit,
but I knew you could tell these gay.
He's a gay guy.
He never had any interest in girls.
Never was around them.
Kind of a,
just an oddly feminine man and uh,
decided to take up the priesthood and we
all treated him
like he was different because he was
going to become
priest is very weird.
Yeah.
The know priests are still treated like
rock stars in the Catholic Church today.
Yeah.
And he was.
Meanwhile I was just another 16 year old
kid just like us,
you know,
maybe he was 17 at the time and I think
I was 15,
but it was just,
he wasn't a different than us,
but we were calling him father and
stuff.
It was just so strange.
I had two uncles that went to seminary.
One of them became a priest and the
other one,
uh,
over the summer I had a friend who got
pregnant and he had to stop being,
get dropped out of the seminary.
Wow.
But when you went to my grandmother's
house as you walked up the steps into
their living room,
the two pictures she would have greeting
you was a picture of both her sons in
their priest outfit.
So one was actually a priest and one had
to go,
but that's the picture she kept up.
Right guys bring it over his four kids
to her house.
There's the picture of Daddy,
why are you in the priest outfit?
One point in time.
So,
so yeah.
That's,
um,
are you,
are you still religious?
You still go to church?
No.
Okay.
No,
I,
I go because my,
I go to church,
a Baptist Church in Pasadena because my,
my mother in law goes and she wanted,
she asked me to go,
oh,
that's probably fun.
And I said,
okay,
I'll go.
I'm being protested by the Westboro
Baptist Church tomorrow are.
You were in Kansas City.
Oh,
very excited.
that is.
Ah,
I've always wanted to be protesting is
good for you
press release.
And they even responded to my,
my,
uh,
I put out a post and they had a tweet,
someone who has no idea what God wants
to speak and forgot that I said that if
God,
you know,
there is a god.
They said I was an atheist,
which I,
I'm really not.
I mean,
I don't consider myself anything.
I don't consider myself religious.
I'm not an atheist.
I'm just a person who doesn't know.
And I don't call it gnostic.
I think I'm more agnostic than anything,
but I don't even want to put a label on
it.
Why should I have to be someone's camp?
You know,
my,
my opinions are allowed to evolve and
I'm allowed to and I've done a lot of
drugs.
I've seen some shit that I can't
explain,
you know,
and psychedelics,
man will,
they'll get whatever confidence you have
that there's no god.
You go through a dmt trip and you come
out and the other and you're like,
okay,
maybe I don't know what the fuck I'm
talking about.
Maybe I don't know anything and that's
I'm in the maybe I don't know anything
camp.
So I said that if where there was a god,
I don't know if there's a god,
but if there was a god,
he or she would probably very
disappointed these hateful twats pretend
to speak for him putting up signs and
say,
God hates fags.
Like you really think this is what God
would want.
That's outrageous.
And so that's what they're excited
about.
That you said that,
that I speak for God.
Oh,
but they could speak for good.
They see God hates fags taking.
See that written anywhere?
Look to the Bible never says God hates
fags.
That's their website is God hates
fags.com.
Just stop and think about that.
I think they should take their facebook
page away.
Do they have a youtube channel?
Westboro Baptist Church.
I have a youtube channel,
but yeah,
but don't.
Don't use speech.
Don't you think we're living in a weird
era of like people wanting to just
discredit people just like get rid of
them.
Like,
oh you,
you,
you don't believe this.
One thing that the establishment says
you have to.
There's only one narrative on this
Syrian war and if you go,
if you go away from it,
you're,
you're a bad person and you're alive and
you're a,
you're an apologist for Assad and you're
a Putin puppet at all.
It's like,
what the fuck?
No,
I just have a different view on the war
and it's based on facts and evidence and
I don't know if you know,
but those people you're trusting now
were the ones who continuously lied to
us.
So I've never lied to you about a war.
You're,
you're upset because I'm skeptical of
the people who constantly lie about war.
It's just the.
And so that's just a weird thing and
it's like this.
But I guess it's probably always been
this way,
Joe.
I don't know,
I just,
now that I'm experienced it because I'm
in the public talking about this stuff
and it's just weird how people are so
quick to go along with the
establishment,
look at how the lefties are defending
the intelligence community.
Wishing Robert Muller of fucking happy
birthday on twitter,
like a bunch of idiots.
So ridiculous.
It's like,
do you guys have any sense of history?
Do you have any sense of recent history?
No,
it's just,
it's,
it shows you how the hatred of someone
could make people's lizard brains
excited and then rational thinking goes
out.
The.
So I love amplicon on my show says,
you know,
uh,
I hate trump as much as anybody,
but I'm not going to let them steal my
critical thinking skills.
And so that's the site.
And so the thing that I like about what
our show does,
we're very consistent.
I don't have one set of rules first.
People I like and another set of rules
for people I have opposed.
And I really,
really appreciate that about you.
And that's one of the things that I said
about you the first time we came on and
say you shoot straight no matter whether
it's right or left,
whatever you see,
you call it,
like you see it.
There's no partisan politics.
And I think that's very important.
And it's so rare it doesn't exist
anymore.
You know,
it was,
I was watching or listening rather than
Sam Harris is one of his podcasts
recently.
Whereas guests made a really important
point saying that we're in this strange
time in history where the news is
different depending on what channel you
watch.
It used to be you at different people
telling you the news,
now you have different news if you
totally different,
totally different news.
Isn't that something?
And it's completely partisan.
I mean it's,
it's 100 percent left or 100 percent
right?
And you're either all in with us.
And I feel like what we're talking about
here and what you're describing is idea
sports like this,
this,
this needing to shut people down.
They want to get a result.
They want to win the game.
You know what?
Right now they just slam dunked on Alex
Jones and they're high fiving all around
the coffee shop.
All the Baristas are fucking psyched.
You know,
they're,
they're really excited to make an
espresso.
Yeah,
we shut them down,
we fucking shut them down and we're
gonna put our masks and our bike locks
are going to whack.
Trump supporters are in the head
tonight.
Like this is is a strange time for
ideas.
You can't,
you can't even,
you can't even objectively assess the
merits of an idea because the ideas have
already been clearly delineated.
Very clearly
acceptable,
acceptable parameters of this
conversation.
These are the acceptable ideas.
And if you go over them,
you are persona non grata.
Yeah.
That's it.
And you know,
meanwhile you turn on NBC,
it's just littered with liars.
Yeah.
And so is Fox and of course you know
what I'd love Shepard Smith.
Shep Smith.
He is a fascinating character.
When he is doing over there is going
against everything.
He goes to get like the.
You ever seen the what Sean Hannity says
versus Shepard Smith?
Yeah.
I've seen those videos.
Fucking hilarious.
Pretty funny.
And he's right.
And he's not right.
He's right.
Constitutionally,
like what he's saying,
when he's describing what Sean Hannity
said versus the reality.
He's right.
He's right in terms of what is a law.
He's right in terms of what you know,
whether or not something is legal or
whether or not it's unethical.
Yeah.
And
you know that that's the thing about
Shep Smith,
like,
uh,
when he gets something wrong,
I think he's just genuinely getting it
wrong.
I don't think it's because he's trying
to push it in there.
He,
he might be unconsciously been
corrupted,
but not consciously.
How did he get over there?
Was the over there?
I don't,
I don't know.
You tell me.
Do you remember when Hannity was on with
combs?
It was Hannity and colmes took the
weasel earliest weakest looking liberal.
They could find a guy.
Looks like he just sweats canola oil and
they put him on TV opposite like this.
Well,
Dino right wingers.
You how sean met him right wingers used
to hire Alan comes to to come perform at
his parties and he would just cower in
the corner.
And I'm kidding.
I feel bad making fun.
Of Him,
because he's not alive anymore.
He's not Alan Colmes.
I'm pretty sure he's dead.
Oh,
when did he die?
A like a year ago or two years ago.
Can you google that and see if he.
I'm pretty nerdy and him split up.
The band broke up long before that.
Yeah.
It's like crosby,
stills,
Nash and young in February.
Last February last year.
So yeah,
he was.
This guy's very nice guy.
I'm sure he was a nice guy,
but it was almost like he didn't get
riled up on
to keep his job.
He got riled up enough to make liberals
look like pushovers and so the people at
home and Kansas and be like stupid
liberals.
Yeah.
Sean Hannity's,
my man.
Sean Hannity's got American.
Yes.
You know,
like Sean Hannity with his big fat white
bread eaten face and that he was just
the one who is telling the truth about
the real problem and the dems in it's.
It's so fascinating to see that video
was Shepard Smith just clearly and,
and,
and very cleanly dissecting everything
that Hannity says.
Well,
the,
the ironic part is right here.
Oh yeah,
that's the video.
Six minutes of it,
and we can't play this though,
right?
There's no evidence to prove any of this
was true after the 18 months.
The Russian investigation is the
opposite of a hoax.
Now,
indictments against Russian
organizations and persons have been
handed up.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
It goes on and on.
It's a Fox News.
Shep Smith shuts down.
Sean Hannity's lies and propaganda.
How is,
how is Shep Smith still at Fox News?
How does that work?
Are you telling me?
It's interesting,
right?
Yeah,
it is.
If this is Sean Hannity's,
eyes look like he's a drugged up.
Yeah,
they're cheesing anchor,
so on some pills,
Isley,
he looks like something's wrong.
Who's the chief anchor of their breaking
news division,
but let me tell you about what Sean
Hannity has been doing is that woman on
Alexandria,
Kazuyo Cortez from New York who beat Joe
Crowley and she's the big democratic
socialists and everybody's got their
bushing and not over it because,
oh my God,
she's the Corporate Democrats hater the
right wind.
She freaks out.
Right?
Because he's actually going to help
people and Sean Hannity has been like
reading out like that.
Look what she likes.
She wants to have medicare for all.
She wants to have free college.
She wants to living wage.
She wants to end the war and people.
I'm sure almost half his audience are
like,
that sounds looking pretty good.
That's A.
I don't know if you know Sean.
Things are tough out here in the
heartland.
Is that possible to do all those things?
I don't have to worry about medical
bills for my fucking kids anymore and I
tried for that.
I don't have to worry about sending my
kids to college.
It's awesome because you have more.
You have endless money for these wars.
I'm sure you have some money for us,
right?
I mean college subsidized,
like why is it so expensive?
So it actually backfiring.
In fact,
I there was a poll that Fox and friends
and friends and friends put out that
said Fox and refresh it.
It said,
do you think the 32 point
$6,000,000,000,000
for Bernie Sanders Medicare for all plan
is worth it?
Of course they left out the other part
which turns out it saves two point
something trillion dollars,
right?
That's the part they leave out to their
gaslighting and their own viewers,
just like all news organizations have
their own viewers.
So they,
that pole pole went up and 73 percent of
the Fox and friends and friends and
friends.
Viewers said they want Bernie Sanders
Medicare for all 73 percent and 30,000
people voted in that bowl.
So that's not just nothing.
So I,
I,
it's,
it's like,
so now they're,
they think that scary socialism scary.
It doesn't scare people anymore because
now there's the internet.
People can go look what it's like to
live in Denmark.
Once a license do say,
do you support Communism,
do sport socialism?
Then people say,
no,
we don't support Communism d support,
medicare yet support social security.
Of course,
for public education.
Yes.
Okay.
Are you support public roads?
Are you for the post office?
We,
for the fire department and put.
Yes.
This is all socialism.
Yeah.
You like libraries,
south socialism and good aspects to it
and so particularly like free health
care.
Who the fuck wants someone that you love
to be shit out of luck where they can't
go to a doctor because they can't afford
it and what if they die?
Come on.
So when I went to Norway and my friend
Steve Owen to Norway to and something
that he noticed his Norwegian,
oh,
did we ever anyway guys and the guys get
the Fellas,
I've got to tell you,
they do wear comically tight pants.
The guys in Europe,
it's like,
you know,
my wife says,
it's like,
you know those,
she goes up to the fashion designers are
fucking with you.
You know that,
right?
It's like,
oh,
I always wanted him to know what your
keys look like.
Shrink wrapped.
That's fantastic.
How many comics you see on stage?
You can see what their fucking phone
make is key.
Oh,
you drive a BMW.
That's nice.
It's like,
what the fuck?
Make sure they can't run away quick.
We have their legs bound up skinny jeans
anyway,
but over there when they talk about a
health care we do,
we go,
you look at you like free healthcare.
They go,
we don't call it free healthcare.
We call it included because it's
included in your taxes.
Just like just like your public
education here,
just like your streets and roads here,
just like your department,
fire department,
your Chi,
it's included.
We don't go.
You get free police,
you get free fire department.
No,
it's included in your Texas road road
maintenance and so that's the funny
thing that Sean Hannity and the right
wing,
they think they can scare people by
saying,
look,
all this stuff,
they're off.
No.
If the Democrats would have been off,
Hillary Clinton would have been offering
people something,
maybe half the country who didn't vote
when it came out and voted for her.
So that's the thing you use.
The Democrats have nothing to offer
people in,
which is why there are a shit show at a
failed party and they've lost their
wiped out at every level of government.
And so if they take over,
it's like if the congress,
there's a big chance to chance they
might.
Uh,
it's just,
again,
it's,
they're,
they're the ones doing the bidding for
trump.
They just handed him more money for
defense than he even asked for.
So if trump had,
here's the thing,
here's the funny thing,
if trump is a maniac,
they'll to say he's unhinged.
He's a maniac.
Haiti shouldn't have his finger on the
button.
Let's give them $80,
million more dollars for bombs.
Those two things are incongruent.
Those don't go together.
So you're bullshitting me on one end or
another.
Do you think he's going to get through
this without going to jail?
He,
um,
yes.
Do you think your son's going to go to
jail?
I,
you know,
I'm not good at predicting things,
but they should all go to jail because
they're probably all corrupt doing
corrupt shit.
But if you put a special prosecutor on
anybody I could,
they'll find crimes on anybody you know,
the,
they're prosecuting manafort for.
It doesn't have anything to do with the
election or trump's campaign.
It's all shit.
Before the trump's campaign,
when he was in collusion with Tony,
but that's the from the Podesta group,
he was funneling money from fucking
Ukraine and they were giving it through
the Podesta found day.
So it is what he's getting charged.
He's,
he's getting charged for shit that
happened before he ever even worked for
trump.
So that's the part they don't tell you.
They go metaphor charge,
but then 80th paragraph,
they go,
this has nothing to do with the
election.
Every articles like that.
So it's just a matter of them deciding
to put a microscope up your ass and find
things you did wrong.
They put a microscope but Bill Clinton's
ass about some land deal in Arkansas and
ended up going to a blowjob in the oval
office and he got impeached for it.
So they got rid of the special
prosecutor after that because they
realize that you'll find crimes on
anybody if you put a special prosecutor.
Um,
and they.
And now they bring it back for trump.
They don't,
they're not prosecuting literal fucking
war criminals.
Joe Literal.
We know their war criminals.
There was a thing called the torture
program.
We know that it was a real thing.
No one goes to jail.
Nobody's prosecuted,
but God dammit,
they got a special prosecutor for trump.
Not that they shouldn't,
but we all know if you put a special
prosecutor on anybody,
Washington,
they're gonna find a lot of fucking
crimes.
Yeah,
they know what they're doing.
That's all the same game of this thing
about not registering as four at age and
so they all played the same game.
They don't register as foreign agents
until they get caught and then the
government allows them to go backtrack
and reregister,
but they're not doing that at all.
We're not going to let but metaphor it.
They eat.
He made a mistake.
So again,
there's ways to oppose trump and the
Russia thing,
isn't it?
The way to oppose trump is you offer
people something else.
He ran to the left of Hillary Clinton on
foreign policy.
He wanted to end our foreign wars is
according to his rhetoric and his
campaign,
he wanted to give everybody healthcare
member.
Everyone's going to get healthcare and
it's going to be cheaper.
That was his.
Of course he stayed.
He's doing the exact opposite.
Yeah,
so who does the thing they say they're
gonna do whatever.
Whoever does the thing.
Who's ever done it?
Oh No,
nobody.
That's why he got.
That's why democracy is not based on
trust.
It's based on mistrust.
It's based on transparency.
You remember that bit?
That bill,
Bill Hicks,
he used to do about a.
That is something along the lines of,
I think that when you get elected,
they bring into a smoky room filled with
globalists and they show you an angle of
the Kennedy assassination that you've
never seen before.
They roll it out.
Any questions?
What's my agenda?
But it almost seems like that's what
happens.
Obama,
Obama changed his tune,
remembering the hope and change website
that had all that shit about
whistleblowers afforded protection.
That was all gone the day he got
elected.
That was a while ago.
It took a while for him being an office
where they realized that it was still in
there on deleted it all.
He disbanded his own followers.
Right.
So when he got elected,
Barack Obama,
he had all these young people who were
activated and they signed up.
He had a mailing list,
eat at all and we want to go do shit for
you want to go back.
And they were like,
get rid of them.
And he did.
He got rid of them because you can't
control them.
They,
yes,
they fuck them.
And that's,
you know.
And you know,
then Bernie Sanders has his campaign and
says,
everybody,
we've got to fight this fucking evil
machine.
And then on a dime he goes,
hey,
by the way,
let's join this evil machine.
It's a little thing happens.
Um,
I don't know.
You know,
I really don't know.
I bought it good at that.
I know what people have said.
Chris Hedges said that Bernie Sanders
didn't want to end up like Ralph Nader
who was unfairly held accountable again
for the Democrats.
The Democrats lost to heal to fucking a
game show host.
And that's what this is all about.
They can't come to terms with this and
they don't want us to examine the system
that gave us trump and they don't want
to examine how they could have the most
qualified person to book couldn't even
beat fucking Donald Trump.
That's how qualified you are.
You.
Well,
they wanted trump to win because they
thought he'd be the easiest guy to beat
in the election.
That was the song.
Isn't it funny that nobody gets mad at
them?
Nobody's upset at Chris Hayes for having
empty podiums of trump for an whole
show,
which I saw and then he wags his finger
at Surandon.
You're the son of a bitch.
You prop trump up and you didn't cover
Bernie Sanders because you were fucking
told not to,
and we know that for a fact because the
Ed Schultz and now you're going to
pretend like you're a sanctimonious
fucking brick and you're going to wag
your finger at people with no money and
no power.
Meanwhile,
you have the biggest microphone of
anybody and you fucking prop Donald
Trump up and you don't take
responsibility.
That's why he's a piece of shit and
couldn't eat.
Very excited,
very excited.
That's why he's doing their bidding
right now.
All those people are doing their bidding
because Ed Schultz revealed and fill
down and you,
if you tell the truth,
they will fucking fire your ass.
They've got guys like Lee Veggie and and
Rachel maddow pretending they don't know
how net neutrality works.
I don't know what it is.
A good as it gets a big thing.
I know it's important,
but I don't know which way we'll see how
it rolls out.
I don't know what the middle.
That's what tools or hate.
I'm not saying I wouldn't do it too.
I'm just not being offered 30 grand a
day to sell my soul.
I would.
It seems confusing to me that they're
thinking about using hillary again
because it seems to me that she's
starting to make her way back into new
cycles and given speeches.
She has a pack that's supposed to be
supporting women who are running for
office except not Cynthia Nixon.
Well,
she's going to prop up the most corrupt
fucker in New York has had for a long
time.
It was supposed to be about just women
whose gender.
She says that's what the gender based.
She said she was starting a pack to help
encourage women to run.
That's.
I read that in an interview with her and
I'm like,
really?
Why isn't that pack?
Then supporting Cynthia Nixon.
Why are you supporting,
you know,
what the fuck she was,
she independent.
She running a Democrat and she's running
against Cuomo.
And um,
so of course I'm was running for mayor.
No governor was running for governor in
New York.
I knew she was running for something I
didn't know was that big.
And you know,
Cuomo is one of the most corrupt.
He said he,
he's just a,
again,
we have one party rule,
we have corporate rule and all these
people are in bed with the corporations
because their body,
because that's the way our elections
work and that's the whole.
That's why Hillary Clinton has a private
position and a public position and I'm
not saying she's the only one,
but she's the one that we know actually
literally said that because of
wikileaks,
thank God.
And that again,
I'll go back to Julian signs.
The fact that none of the reporters in
the United States are sticking up for
Julian Assan shows you that what they do
is fucking wrestling and they don't do
real journalism wrestling.
And what's really interesting about the
Julia naissance things,
if you ask people what he did that
because of the reductionist thinking,
because of the,
they've allowed this narrative to play
for it.
They'll say he's accused of sexual
assault and when you find out the actual
facts of it,
his woman consensual sex and then the
middle of the night he stuck it in
without a condom.
And they were calling.
They were calling it surprised sex.
I don't know.
But there's no.
I mean it didn't make any sense.
And why the pressure him to the United
States for surprise sex that he had in.
Where was it?
Norway or somewhat the first.
Of course they want to kind of come at
you.
Of course,
if they want to get the CIA wants to get
you the first thing to do,
oh he's probably by betsy.
He's a rapist.
Let's get some going.
And that whole prosecutor who tries to
prosecutor was discredited for doing so.
They were apologized to Julian asides
the UN stuck up for his.
Stood up for Julian to size and the
woman.
So this is why they're still.
They still have them.
Hold up in the Ecuadorian embassy.
What is he going to do?
They want to kick him out,
right?
Well,
the ACL was,
I think supporting him in the United
States.
So,
and you know,
certain people of character or are,
are supporting him or not him,
but the idea of journalistic integrity,
freedom of speech,
the right to publish.
If you watch that movie,
the post,
which was all about Daniel Ellsberg and
the,
and the Vietnam,
uh,
the Pentagon papers which expose that
for administrations were lying to us
about the Vietnam War.
Not a Republican,
not a democrat.
They're all again the same.
Fucking two wings of the same party to
right wings.
It's the military industrial party.
And the hero of that movie is the woman
who was the head of the Washington Post.
Not Daniel Ellsberg.
He was a real fucking hero.
But how can you make that movie in this
day and age and not mentioned Chelsea
manning not mentioned Edward Snowden and
not go,
you know,
Daniel Ellsberg's up today.
We imprison them and that's what we're
doing.
We in prison,
the Daniel Ellsberg's up today,
and everybody who watched panels of the
actors from that movie and the director
and sit around and talk,
nobody ever brings the shit up.
It's unfucking believable to me that
they don't understand that they're just,
they're doing pr.
That's propaganda.
Look how good our Washington Post
Washington Post went on to lead us into
every fucking war after that movie was
supposedly made,
right?
So after,
after they did that and they printed
that,
they backed every goddamn more sense.
They're the ones who told us that Saddam
had weapons of mass destruction.
And it was irrefutable.
That was the headline on their editorial
page.
It wasn't [inaudible].
It was their editorial board said air
refutable doubt always at that fake news
should they have their facebook page
taken down that actually led to the
fucking death of millions of people.
So,
um,
this is what this is.
This is why I have a show.
This is what I'm talking about.
And thank God the a.
In a sense,
thank God the media sucks so bad because
now I get to do their job and I'm a
fucking idiot.
I'm a C student Jag off nightclub
comedian and I do my job better than
they do.
Well,
you don't have a boss.
That's the thing,
not you're not beholding to anybody.
I was just offered a TV show and I want
to say by who,
and I'm a,
I was Satan and I was offered anything I
wanted me.
You want to do,
do you want to do five days in the
morning?
You want to do one day a week?
You want to do this?
I'll give you your own studio,
your own crew,
the whole deal.
And I had to look at the guy and I said,
you have been waiting my whole career
for somebody to make me an offer like
this.
And I just have to tell you know things.
Wow.
And he's like,
what?
What do you want?
And I said,
I don't want anything.
I already have everything I want.
And um,
he and I got to want to drive across
town to go do a show and somebody else's
studio.
I walk out my back door,
I do my show in my garage.
I don't fucking need your money.
I don't need a boss,
I don't need it.
I'm selling out theaters right now.
That's what I want to do.
I go,
I don't want to.
I want to spend less time in the studio,
more time tutoring,
because that's fun,
dude.
It is unbelievable.
I,
the best part of my life is right now.
It's unbelievable.
I'm so glad I didn't kill myself eight
years ago.
I was so.
I was so close to killing myself.
I'm so glad I did it.
And it was my hatred for people that
kept me alive.
Amazing.
Because was.
I didn't want people.
I already said this to you.
I didn't want people to go out high.
He didn't make it.
I was like,
fuck you.
I am making it and then I'm going to
kill myself.
I don't say that.
They'll use that as a see that that
killed himself.
He didn't get suicided.
It didn't get silenced.
I didn't.
So I was,
I was just back in Chicago and I played
a place called Thalia Hall,
which is fucking,
that's where Brian Callen just did his,
uh,
his new special beautiful.
Have a video up from that show on my
channel.
It was so I used to live in,
when I started to be a comedian,
I moved to that neighborhood.
It was back then.
It wasn't a nice neighborhood,
right?
It was like a tougher neighborhood,
but I got to live closer to the city and
all my comedian friends live there
because it was affordable and now it's
being gentrified and shit and they've
got this new theater and it's.
I mean it's not new,
but it's old and they refurbished it and
it's 600 people and I came out and it
was just like,
it was just like heaven,
you know,
and I get my whole career.
I tried to figure out how to get people
to stand up at the end of my set.
Like how do I get what I don't want to
do it in a shitty way.
I want to manipulate them,
but I want to have come from my heart
and inspire people and make them want to
stand up,
you know,
to get a standing ovation.
Right.
And now they stand up when I come out.
Wow.
I don't have to worry about it.
It's already done.
So this is the greatest time of my life
and it's because nobody,
you know,
people can't get anywhere else.
What I'm doing,
uh,
is just nothing else like it.
You know,
Bill Maher of God bless his soul,
you know,
he's a corporatist and he's part of the
problem.
Right.
And I like,
I like Bill Maher.
I'd love to.
I read his book that he read about who
wrote about common.
I bet you ain't even know he had one.
It was,
it was really funny.
No,
no,
no.
The uh,
the novel.
I wrote that true.
I think it was called true story story.
Yeah.
I love that.
That's a great book.
Twice was the one guy's name.
Shit.
Fuck.
Chink.
And something else.
He better be careful.
You better be careful because that's
enough about that book.
Ethnic slur,
right?
The characters names.
That's right.
Those from the eighties,
nineties,
nineties.
Yeah.
So he wrote about it.
He wrote about how it comedy modern day
comedy got started and how it was really
interesting book about he would go on
the road and it would be the,
he'd be the first comedian that club had
ever seen and they didn't know.
He was like,
the waitresses didn't know he was
leaving the next week.
Shit like that.
It was like,
it didn't sink in how things work.
It was such an interesting book to read
anyway,
but now he's,
you know,
he brags that he gave a million dollars
to Barack Obama,
which fantastic too.
But did he really?
Yeah.
I'm not on air so,
you know,
it's just like I get it.
I W I aspire to be Bill Maher.
I aspire to be a millionaire for 30
years and a little bit out of touch.
That's good for you.
You did it.
Oh God.
So anyway,
but it's good.
You know,
again,
I get upset because I want him to be
better or be more like I want them to
be,
but it actually helps me.
Right.
So the more he's he shifts to the right,
the more his audience comes to me,
right?
And the more I get on stage,
I'll have to do as much as an ame on
stage at a live show and people fuck,
boom.
Right?
Yeah.
It's progressives don't like him.
Now he's.
He doesn't not happen.
When did that happen for Bernie Sanders
campaign?
Real.
He doesn't get that.
There's a difference that there's a
difference between the Hillary and
Bernie Sanders.
How could he not get it?
You tell me.
He,
he's had we,
we,
I played videos of him saying that.
Yeah.
Now they were basically the same.
What's the big deal?
Then?
These progressives are just being
babies.
And isn't it funny?
Progressives are being babies when they
won't support warmongering corporatists,
but centrus corporatist start being
adults.
When they fuck over progressive's,
they don't.
They don't ever accommodate them.
They don't ever drop their values and
come over and be progressive.
We're always supposed to go that way.
They never go the other way.
That unity means,
hey,
you guys shut the fuck up and fall in
line and become a corporatist.
That's what they mean when they say
unity and it ain't happening,
and I'm telling you,
Bernie Sanders is making a big mistake
by not starting a third party right now.
That's how you influence.
If he does not win the Democratic
nomination in 20 slash 20,
what is he built over these four years?
Fucking nothing.
Do you think he's going to run?
Run in 20 slash 20?
Yes.
That's what this is all about.
Thought he had said he was done.
I thought he said he wasn't gonna.
Try again.
He's running again.
He thinks if there's.
I'll make that prediction.
Yeah,
I'll make that prediction that you a
dollar.
I'll bet you $2 doubled down.
Five bucks.
Okay.
All right.
I'll go five bucks.
So I'll tell you how you can afford five
bucks.
Best time of my life.
I can't believe.
I can't believe how amazing.
It's so nice to not have no
representation right now,
by the way.
I have not been better.
It's almost yes.
That's even better.
You get all the Cheddar.
I was working.
I was working with this guy,
Alex Murray,
who's a great guy.
I love Alex Murray and he got me
specials.
You got to be comedy central specialist
who especially special.
He sold a book for me.
Fucking great guy.
I love Alex Murray,
but he got real busy,
right?
He represents a bunch of really Chris
hardwick and know he had anyway and Jim
Gaffigan,
all these guys he represents.
So he got too busy for me,
which I understand.
It was weird.
He stopped,
so we stopped working together.
Right.
Is My show.
Ah,
right.
Is that like what the fuck?
And all of a sudden people started
showing up at clubs when I'm there and
I'm like,
Whoa,
whoa.
And we start selling out weeks ahead of
time.
I did the Chicago theater in how many
seats is that?
Thirty 700.
Jesus,
you are popular.
Pretty popular.
Jesus Christ.
Don't know what happened,
but I did the Chicago theater many years
ago and I remember saying something
about the podcast and I said,
how many you guys listen to the podcast?
And it was a roar through the crowd.
And I went,
whoa.
That was when I realized I was like,
Oh yeah.
Was going on.
Yeah.
Like I didn't think I thought I was
going to be like 10 percent of the
people.
I got it.
I don't,
I don't pay attention to anything,
man.
This is one of the secrets from me
staying me and people and people have
accused me of changing.
It's called I evolve as a person.
I,
I learn more.
I studied myself.
I'm ruthlessly
critical of myself.
I'm very analytical,
self analytical,
and I don't like a lot of the stuff I
do.
This is just so I get better at it
hopefully.
But,
um,
I just didn't know that anybody was
paying attention.
I didn't,
wasn't.
I wasn't looking.
I don't look at numbers.
I occasionally look and I go to,
I don't want any think about that and I
don't think about it.
I just do it.
But that moment where I was in front of
3,700
people and know how many guys listened
to the podcast and I went,
I was like,
Whoa,
okay.
This is not what I expected.
I thought it was going to be a bunch of
people,
people like,
no ma'am,
no fear booked or UFC whatever.
And um,
that's when I realized something was
going on there.
That's a weird feeling,
right?
When you realize all these people are
coming to see you because of something
you did yourself.
Yeah.
It was the yes,
because it's something you did and it
was,
it was when I stopped trying almost.
There's one
marilyn,
Marilyn stop trying is when w WTF?
Yes.
That same with me.
Like when I stop censoring myself or
overthinking,
like I would go on stage and I would
have my jokes down to a science.
Right.
And that's obviously youtube is not that
way and I just let it rip and that's the
thing that connected with people.
It's so amazing.
And it,
and the Burbank Burbank Comedy Festival
at that flappers comedy club and they
asked me to go,
would you do your podcast here at 5:00
on a Thursday or whatever.
And I was like okay,
I'll do it for you.
Whatever.
And I did about five people there who's
going to fucking show up at 5:00
on a Thursday in Burbank,
right?
Places almost full.
And I was like,
oh,
that's what I was like,
Woo,
what the fuck's going on?
Five o'clock.
And there were,
there were girls there.
I am not,
I'll never forget this,
that they came from Compton when they
were like,
oh,
we had to get off work.
We had to get a ride.
When we got here,
we worked.
He had to see.
And I was like,
wow,
I'm really connecting with people right?
That,
that don't look like me,
but they share the same ideology and it
just,
it's like when I would go see George
Carlin,
if you ever went and saw him live,
there were 80 year old hippies and they
were a teenager kids and there was
everybody in between and that's what it
looks like at my shows.
And it makes me so fucking happy.
It's so that's when it,
that's when it's.
I was like,
whoa.
And I was like,
thanks flappers for making me do this
show,
because now I realize,
and Jimmy,
I'm happy for you too,
and I,
I really think that you're one of the
only people out there that really
doesn't toe a line one way or the other.
You really do speak the truth.
And I said that about you the first time
I said about you before I ever had you
on.
I was like,
this guy just says what he thinks.
Whether you agree with them or disagree
with them,
you can't point to him and say,
Oh,
this guy is just a left wing hack,
or this guy is a right wing apologist,
or whatever it is.
You just say what you think and that is
so refreshing and it's so valuable.
There's just not enough of that today.
There's not enough.
And these people that are super
intelligent that think that if you vote
one way it's a protest vote and he
shouldn't have a protest vote because
you're throwing away your vote and you
gonna let the right wing people when
like you're missing everything.
You're missing this whole thing.
This whole thing is super complicated,
it's very complicated and the only way
to see through the haze is to be honest
and you're one of the only people that's
doing it.
Well.
I really appreciate you saying that and
I think that there's a lot of common
ground,
especially when it comes to getting
corporations fingers out of our
government and ending wars.
I think a lot of people agree on that
and that actually scares the
establishment.
Yeah,
I think it does.
Jimmy.
Joe,
thanks for being here,
man.
Thanks for having me.
I really,
really appreciate it.
Tell people how they get your show.
Tell people what your twitter page.
Just go to Jimmy Dore,
comedy.com.
That's my website and we're on the
youtube at youtube.com/the
Jimmy Dore Show and I'm on twitter,
Jimmy underscore door,
the whole thing.
I appreciate you brother.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
To Jimmy Dot.
Ladies and gentlemen.